battle not with monsters lest ye become
a monster and if you gaze into the abyss
the abyss gazes also into you right but
i would say
bring it on
if you gaze into the abyss long enough
you see the light not the darkness
are you sure about that
i'm betting my life on it
the following is a conversation with
jordan peterson an influential
psychologist lecturer podcast host and
author of maps of meaning 12 rules for
life
and beyond order
this is the lex friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's jordan
peterson
dostoevsky wrote in the idiot spoken
through the character of prince mishkin
that beauty will save the world
soulja nissan actually mentioned this in
his nobel prize
acceptance speech what do you think this
yes game meant by that was he right
well
i guess it's the divine that saves the
world let's say you could say that by
definition
and then you might say well
are there pointers to that which will
save the world or that which eternally
saves the world and
the answer to that in all likelihood is
yes and that's maybe truth and love and
justice
and
the classical virtues beauty
perhaps in some sense foremost among
them it's a that's a difficult case to
make but definitely a pointer which
direction is the arrow pointing well the
arrow is pointing up no i think that
that which it points to is what beauty
points to it transcends beauty it's more
than beauty and that speaks to the
divine
it points to the divine
yeah and i would say again by definition
because we could define the divine in
some real sense
so one way of defining the divine is
what is divine to you is your most
fundamental axiom and you might say well
i don't have a fundamental axiom then i
would say that's fine but then you're
just confused
because you have a bunch of
contradictory axioms and you might say
well i have no axioms at all and then
i'd say well you're just
epistemologically ignorant beyond
comprehension if you think that because
that's just not true at all but you
don't think a human being can exist
within contradictions
well yeah we have to exist within
contradiction but
when the contradictions make themselves
manifest
say in confusion with regard to
direction
then
the consequence of that technically is
anxiety
and frustration and disappointment and
all sorts of other negative emotions but
the cardinal negative emotion
signifying
multiple pathways forward
is anxiety it's an entropy signal
but you don't think that kind of
entropy signal can be channeled into
into beauty into love why does beauty
and love have to be clear ordered
simple well i would say
it probably doesn't have to be
it can't be reduced to clarity and
simplicity
because when it's optimally structured
it's a balance between order and chaos
not order itself if it's too ordered if
music is too ordered it's not it's not
acceptable it sounds like a drum machine
it's too repetitive it's too predictable
it has to have well it has to have some
fire in it
along with the structure
i was in miami doing a seminar on
exodus with a number of scholars and
this is a beauty discussion
when moses first encounters the burning
bush
it's not a conflagration that
demands attention it's something that
catches his attention
it's a phenomena and that means to shine
forth and moses has to stop and attend
to it and he does and he sees this
fire that doesn't consume the tree and
the tree the tree is a structure right
it's a tree-like structure it's a
branching structure it's a hierarchical
structure
it's a self-similar structure it's a
fractal structure
and it's the tree of life and it's the
tree of the knowledge of good and evil
and
the fire in it is the transformation
that's always occurring within every
structure and the fact that the fire
doesn't consume the bush in that
representation is
a an indication of the balance of
transformation with structure and that
balance is presented as god and what
attracts
moses to it in some sense is the beauty
now it's the novelty and all that but
like a painting is like a burning bush
that's a good way of thinking about it a
great painting it's too much for people
often you know i my house
was and will soon be again completely
covered with paintings inside
and
it was hard on people to come in there
because
well my mother for example say well why
would you want to live in a museum
and i'd think well i would rather live
in a museum than anywhere else in some
real sense but
beauty is daunting it scares people
they're terrified of buying art for
example because their taste is on
display and they should be terrified
because generally people have terrible
taste now that doesn't mean they
shouldn't foster it and develop it but
and you know when you put your taste on
display it's a real really exposes you
even to yourself as you walk past it oh
dear every day
this is who i am yeah well and and look
how mundane that is and look how trite
it is and look at how cliched it is and
look at how sterile or too ordered it is
or too chaotic or how quickly you start
to take it for granted because you've
seen it so many times well if it's a
real piece of art that doesn't happen
you notice the little details the whole
is greater than the sum of the parts i
mean there are images
religious images in particular so we
could call them deep images
that people have been unpacking
for
4 000 years and still have i'll give you
an example
this is a terrible example
so i did a lecture series on genesis
and i got a lot of it unpacked but by no
means all of it
when god kicks adam and eve out of the
garden of eden
he puts cherubim with flaming swords at
the gate to stop human beings from
re-entering paradise
i thought what the hell does that mean
cherubim and why do they have flaming
swords i don't get that what is that
exactly
and then i found out from matthew pagio
who wrote a great book on symbolism in
genesis that cherubim are the supporting
monsters of god it's a very complicated
idea
and that they're partly a representation
of that which is difficult to fit into
conceptual systems
they've also got an angelic or demonic
aspect
take your pick why do they have flaming
swords well a sword is a symbol of
judgment and
and
and
the separation of the wheat from the
chaff use a sword to cut away
to cut away
and to carve
and a flaming sword is not only that
which carves it's that which burns
and what does it carve away and burn
well you want to get into paradise
it carves away everything about you that
isn't perfect
and so what does that mean okay well
here's part of what it means this is a
terrible thing
so
you could say that the entire christian
narrative is embedded in that image
why
well let's say that flaming swords are a
symbol of death
that seems pretty obvious
let's say further
that they're a symbol of apocalypse and
hell
that doesn't seem completely
unreasonable
so here's an idea
not only do you have to face death
you have to face death and hell
before you can get to paradise
hellish judgment
and all that's embedded in that image
and and a piece of art with an image
like that has all that information in it
and it shines forth in some fundamental
sense
it it reaches into the back tendrils of
your mind at levels you can't even
comprehend
and grips you
i mean that's why people go to museums
and
gays at paintings they don't understand
and that's why they'll pay what's the
most expensive objects in the world if
it's not carbon fiber racing yachts it's
definitely classic paintings
right it's high level technological
implements
or it's classic art well why are those
things so expensive why do we build
temples to house the images even secular
people go to museums
i'm secular well are you in a museum yes
are you looking at art yes well
what makes you think you're secular then
it's arguable that the thing
many many centuries from now that will
remain of all of human civilization will
be our art
not even the words well you know the a
book has remained a very long time right
the biblical reasons that long uh
humanity that's right
but that's in the full arc of living
organisms perhaps will not well we have
images that are we have artistic images
that are at least 50 000 years old right
that have survived
and some of those are
they're already profound in their
symbolism
yeah we found them and and and
they've lasted they've lasted that long
and so and then
think about europe
secular people all over the world make
pilgrimages to europe
well why
because of the beauty
obviously i mean
that's self-evident
and it's partly because there are things
in europe that are so beautiful they
take your breath away right they make
your hair stand on and they fill you
with a sense of awe
and
and
we need to see those things it's not
optional we need to see those things the
cathedrals was in the cathedral in
vienna and it was terribly beautiful you
know terribly well it was terribly
beautiful is beauty painful for you
is is that the highest form of beauty it
really challenges you oh definitely
yeah yeah i got a good analysis of the
statue of david michelangelo says you
could be far more than you are
that's what that statue says
and this cathedral you know down we went
down into the into the
under structure of it and there were
three floors of bones
from the plague and there they all are
and then that cathedral is on top of it
it's no joke to go visit a place like
that
no it's it it rattles you to the core
and our
our
religious systems have become
propositionally dubious
but there's no arguing with the
architecture although modern architects
like to with their sterility and their
giant middle fingers erected everywhere
but
beauty is a is a terrible pointer to god
and you know a secular person will say
well i don't believe in god it's like
have it your way
you gotta
you cannot move forward into the
unforeseen horizon of the future except
on faith
and you might say well i have no faith
it's like well good luck with the future
then because
what are you then nihilistic and
hopeless and anxiety-ridden
and if not well something's guiding you
forward it's faith in something or
multiple things which just makes you a
polytheist which i wouldn't recommend
well let me ask you one short-lived
biological meat bag to another
who is god then
let's try to sneak up to this question
if it's at all possible is it possible
to even
talk about this
well it better be because otherwise
there's no communicating about it right
it it has to be something that can be
brought down to earth
well we might be too dumb to bring it
down it's not just ignorant it's also
sinful
right
so because there's not knowing and then
there's not wanting to know or refusing
to know yeah and so you might say well
could you extract god from a description
of the objective world
right is is god just the ultimate unity
of
of of
of the natural reality and i would say
well
in a sense there's some truth in that
but but not exactly because
god in the highest sense is the spirit
that you must emulate in order to
thrive
how's that for a biological definition
spirit is a pattern
the spirit that you must emulate in
order to thrive so it's a kind of uh in
one sense
when we say the human spirit
it's that it's an animating principle
yeah it's a meta it's a pattern
and you might say well what's the
pattern okay well i can tell you that to
some degree
imagine that
like you're grip by beauty
you're gripped by admiration
so and you can just notice this this
isn't propositional you have to notice
it it's like oh
turns out i admire that person
so what does that mean well it means i
would like to be like him or her
that's what admiration means it means
there's something about the way they are
that compels imitation
another instinct
or inspires respect or awe
even
okay what is that that grips you
well
i don't know well let's say okay fine
but it grips you and you want to be like
that kids hero worship for example so do
adults for that matter unless they
become entirely cynical i worship quite
a quite a few heroes yeah well there you
go proudly yes well there you go and
there's no that worship that celebration
and proclivity to imitate is worship
that's what worship means most
fundamentally now imagine you took
the set of all admirable people and you
extracted out ai learning you extracted
out the central features of what
constitutes admirable
and then you did that repeatedly until
you purified it to what was most
admirable
that's as good as you're going to get
in
in terms of a representation of god
and you might say well i don't believe
in that it's like
well
what do you mean yeah it's not a set of
propositional facts
it's not a scientific theory about the
structure of the objective world and
then i could say something about that
too because i've been thinking about
this a lot especially since talking to
richard dawkins
it's like okay
the post-modernist types
going back way before daradan foucault
maybe back to nietzsche
who i admire greatly by the way
he says god is dead
it's like okay
but nietzsche said god is dead and we
have killed him and will not find enough
water to wash away all the blood so that
was nietzsche he's no fool he's got away
with words he certainly does
and so then you think okay well we
killed the transcendent
well
what does that mean for science well it
frees it up because all that nonsense
about a deity is just the idiot
superstition that stops the scientific
um
what process from moving forward that's
basically the new atheist claim
something like that it's like wait a
second
do you believe in the transcendent if
you're a scientist
and the answer is
well not only do you believe in it you
believe in it more than anything else
because if you're a scientist
you believe in
what objects to your theory
more than you believe in your theory now
we've got to think that through very
carefully so your theory describes the
world and as far as you're concerned
your description of the world is the
world
but because you're a scientist you think
well even though that's my description
of the world and that's what i believe
there's something beyond what i believe
and that's the object and so i'm going
to throw my theory against the object
and see where it'll break
and then i'm going to use the evidence
of the break
as a source of new information to
revitalize my theory so as a scientist
you have to posit the existence of the
ontological transcendent before you can
move forward at all but more
you have to pause it that contact with
the ontological transcendent
annoying though it is because it upsets
your apple cart is exactly what will in
fact set you free
so then you accept the proposition that
there is a transcendent reality
and that the that contact with that
transcendent reality is redemptive in
the most fundamental sense because if it
wasn't why would you bother making
contact with you're going to make
everything worse or better
why does the
contact with the transcendent
set you free as a scientist because you
assume that you assume i mean freedom in
the most fundamental sense it's like
well freedom from want freedom from
disease freedom from ignorance right
that it informs you
the logos in it of science
it is definitely that
yeah it's it's the what it's the
direction let's say the directionality
of science that's a narrative direction
not a scientific direction and then the
question is what is the narrative well
it posits a transcendent reality it
posits that the transcendent reality is
corrective it posits that our knowledge
structure should be regarded with
humility it posits that you should bow
down in the face of
of the transcendent evidence and you
have to take a vow you know this as a
scientist you have to take a vow to
follow that path if you're going to be a
real scientist it's like the truth no
matter what and that means you posit the
truth as a redemptive force
well what does redemptive mean well why
bother with science well so people don't
starve so people can move about more
effectively so life can be more abundant
right so it's all ensconced within an
underlying ethic so the the reason i i
was saying that while we were talking
about belief in god it's like this is a
very complicated topic right do you
believe in a transcendent reality see
okay now let's say
you buy the argument i just made on the
natural front you say yeah yeah that's
just nature
that's not god
and then i'd say well what makes you
think you know what nature is
like see the problem with that argument
is that it it already presumes
a materialist a reductionist materialist
objective view of what constitutes
nature but if you're a scientist you're
going to think
well in the final analysis i don't know
what nature is i certainly don't know
its origin or destination point i don't
know it's teleology i'm really ignorant
about nature
and so when i say it's nothing but
nature
i shouldn't mean it's nothing but what i
understand nature to be
so i could say will we have a fully
reductionist account of cognitive
processes
and the answer to that is yes but by the
time we do that our understanding of
matter will have transformed so much
that what we think of as reductionists
now won't look anything like this what
we think of reductionism now
matter isn't dead
dust
i don't know what it is
i have no idea what it is matter is what
matters there's a definition that's a
very weird definition but
the notion that we have
you know that if you're a reductionist a
materialist reductionist that you can
reduce
the complexity of what is to your
assumptions about the nature of matter
that's not a scientific your specific
limited human assumptions of this
century of this week that
so in that in some sense
without god
in this complicated big definition we're
talking about
the there's no humility or
it's not enough there's less likely to
be
or rather science can err in taking a
trajectory away from humility well
without something much more powerful
than uh individual human yeah well then
and we know you know the frankenstein
story comes out of that instantly and
that's a good story for the current
times it's like
you you're playing around with making
new life
you bloody well better make sure you
have your arrows pointed up
and it's interesting because you said
science has
um an ethic to it
i think it's embedded in an ethic well
there's a
you know
science is a big word yeah and it
includes a lot of disciplines that have
different traditions so biology
chemistry
uh genetics physics
those are very different communities
and i think biology especially when you
get closer and closer to medicine into
the human body
does have a very serious first of all
has a history with nazi germany of being
abused and all those kinds of things but
it has a history of taking this stuff
seriously what doesn't have a history of
taking this stuff seriously is robotics
and artificial intelligence which is
really interesting
because
you don't uh you know you called me a
scientist but
and i i would like to wear that label
proudly but often people don't think of
computer science as a science but
nevertheless it will be i think the
science of one of the major scientific
fields of the 21st century and you
should take that very seriously
oftentimes when people build robots
or ai systems they think of them
as
toys to tinker with oh isn't this cool
well i feel this too isn't this cool it
is cool
but
you know uh at a certain moment you
might
isn't this nuclear
uh explosion cool yes it is or birth
control pill cool it's like or or
transistor cool yeah well the other
thing too and and this is a weird
problem in some sense the robotics
engineer types they're thing people
right i mean the big classes of interest
are interesting things versus interest
in people some of my best friends are
thing people yeah right and thing people
are very very
clear logical thinkers and they're very
outcome oriented and practical
now and that's all good that makes the
machinery and keeps it functioning
but
there's a human side of the equation and
and you get the extreme thing people and
you think yeah well what about the human
here and
when we're talking about we've been
talking about the necessity of having a
technological enterprise embedded in an
ethic and you can ignore that like most
of the time right you can ignore the
overall ethic in some sense when you're
toying around with your toys but when
you're building an artificial
intelligence it's like well
that's not a toy
that might be
toy becomes the monster very quickly
yeah yeah yes yes and and this is a
whole new kind of monster
and maybe it's already here
yes and you notice how many of those
things you can no longer turn off
and what is it with you engineers and
your inability to put off switches on
things now
it's like i have to hold this for five
seconds for it to shut off or i can't
figure i just want to shut it off click
off well what is it with you humans that
don't uh put all switches on other
humans because there's a magic to the
thing that you notice and it hurts
uh for both you and perhaps one day the
thing itself to turn it off
and so you have to be very careful as an
engineer adding off switches to things
um i think it's a feature not a bug the
off switch
the off switch gives a deadline to us
humans to systems
of existence it makes you uh it's you
know death
is the thing that really brings clarity
to life and i do think yes hence the
flaming swords the flaming sword i do
like your view of the flame with the
bush and perhaps the sword as a thing of
transformation it's also
it's a transformation that kind of
consumes the thing in the process well
it depends on how much of the thing is
chaff
you know this is why you can't touch the
ark of the covenant
for example and this is why people can
have very bad psychedelic trips
it's like if you're 95 dead wood
and you get too close to the flame
the five percent that's left might not
be able to make it
so you think it's all chat but i think
there is some aspect of destruction that
is
that's you know the the bukowski line of
uh do what you love and let it kill you
right don't you think it that
destruction is part of that's humility
that's humility you bet you bet you bet
it's like
invite in the judgment invite in the
judgment because maybe you can die a
little bit instead of dying completely
yeah you know that's i think it's alfred
north whitehead
we can let our ideas die instead of us
right we can have these partial
personalities that we can burn off
and we can let them go before they
become tyrannical pharaohs and
everything and we lose everything
and so yeah there's this optimal bite of
death and who knows
what it would mean to optimize that like
what if it was possible that if you died
enough all the time
that you could continue to live and the
thing is we already know that
biologically because
if you don't die properly all the time
well it's cancerous outgrowths and and
like it's a very fine balance between
productivity on the biological front and
the culling of that right
life is a real balance between growth
and death
and so what would happen if you got that
balance right well we kind of know right
because
if you live your life properly
so to speak and you're humble enough to
let your stupidity die before it takes
you out you will live longer that's just
a fact
well but then what's the ultimate
extension of that and the answer is we
don't know we have no idea
well let me ask you a difficult question
because as opposed to the easy ones that
you've been asking so far well uh
dostoevsky is always just the warm-up
so if death if if if death every single
day is the way to progress through life
you have become quite famous death in
hell
death in hell yeah yeah because you
don't want to forget the hell part
uh do you worry that your fame
traps you
into the person
that you were before yeah well yeah
elvis became an elvis impersonator by
the time he died yeah do you fear that
you have become a jordan peterson
impersonator that do you fear of in some
part becoming
the famous suit wearing
brilliant jordan peter this the
certainty in the pursuit of truth
right i think i worry about it more than
anything else i hope
i hope i do i better has fame to some
degree when you look at yourself in the
mirror
in the quiet of your mind has it
corrupted you
no doubt in some regard i mean it's very
difficult thing to
avoid you know because
things change around you people are much
more likely to do
what you ask for example right and so
that's a danger because one of the
things that keeps you dying properly is
that people push back against you
optimally this is why so many
celebrities spiral out of control
especially the tyrannical types that say
run countries
everyone around them stops saying yeah
you're you're you're deviating a little
bit there they laugh at all their jokes
they open all their doors they they
always want something from them the red
carpet's always rolled out it's like
well you think would that be lovely it's
well
not if the red carpet is rolled out to
you well you're on your way to perdition
that's not a good deal you just get
there more efficiently
and so one of the things
that i've tried to learn to manage is to
get have people around me all the time
who are critics
who are saying
yeah i could have done that better and
you're a little too harsh there and
you're alienating people unnecessarily
there and you should have done some more
background work there and
and i think the responsibility attendant
upon that increases as your influence
increases and that's
that's a as your influence increases
then that becomes a lot of
responsibility
so you know and then maybe have an off
day and well one here's an example
i've been writing some columns lately
about things that perturb me
like the forthcoming famine for example
and
it's hard to take those
um problems on
it's difficult to take those problems on
in a serious manner and it's frightening
and it would be easier just to go up to
the cottage with my wife and go out on
the lake and watch the sunset
and so
i'm tempted to draw on
anger as a motivating energy
to help me overcome the
resistance to doing this
but then that makes me more harsh and
judgmental in my tone
when i'm reading such things for example
on youtube
then might be optimal now i've had
debates about with people about that
because i have friends who say
no if you're calling out the
environmental
environmentalist globalists who are
harassing the dutch farmers
then a little anger is just the ticket
but then others say well you know you
don't want to be too harsh because you
alienate people who would otherwise
listen to you it's like
that's a hard balance to get right but
also maybe anger
hardens your mind to where you don't
notice the the subtle quiet beauty of
the world
the quiet love that's always there that
permeates everything sometimes you can
become deeply cynical about the world if
it's the nietzsche thing yeah battle not
with monsters lest ye become a monster
and if you gaze into the abyss the abyss
gazes also into you right but i would
say
bring it on
right because well i also say knowing
that he's absolutely right but
if you gaze into the abyss long enough
you see the light not the darkness
are you sure about that
i'm betting my life on it
yeah it's a heck of a bet well that's
because it might distort your mind
to where
all you see
is it this is is abyss is the evil in
this world i would say you haven't
looked long enough
you know that's back to the you're just
the limited the swords the flaming
swords it's like
so i said the whole story of christ was
prefigured in that image
it's like the story of christ
psychologically
is
radical acceptance of the worst possible
tragedy that's what it means that's what
the crucifix means psychologically it's
like gays upon that which you are most
afraid of but that story doesn't end
there because in in the in the story
christ goes through death into hell
so death isn't enough
the abyss the abyss of innocent death is
not sufficient to produce redemption
it has to be a voluntary journey to hell
and maybe that's true for everyone
and that's like there is no more
terrifying idea than that by definition
and so then well do you gaze upon that
well
who knows
who knows how often do you gaze upon
death your own
how often do you
remember remind yourself that this ride
ends personally personally
all the time because you as a as a deep
thinker and philosopher it's easy to
start philosophizing
and and forgetting that you're
you might die to the angel of death sits
on every word
how's that
i how often do you actually consciously
all the time
uh notice the angel all the time
i think it's one of the things that made
me peculiar
when i was in graduate school you know i
i thought about i was
i had the thought of death in my mind
all the time
and i noticed that many of the people
that i was with these were people i
admired fine they that wasn't part of
their character but it was definitely
part of mine i'd wake up every morning
this happened for years think
time short get at it time short get at
it
there's things to do
and so that was always that's still
there and it's still there with i would
say and it's unbearable in some sense
are you afraid of it like what
relationship yeah you know i was ready
to die
a year ago
and not casually i had people i loved
you know
so no i'm not very worried about me but
i'm very worried about making a mistake
yeah
i heard elon musk talk about that a
couple of months ago it was really a
striking moment
someone asked him about death and he
said just off hand and then went on with
the conversation he said i'd be a relief
and then he went on with the
conversation
and i thought
well you know
he's got a lot of weight on his
shoulders
i'm sure that part of them thinks
i'd be easier just if this wasn't here
at all
now he said it offhand but it was a
telling moment in my estimation so for
him that's a
why live question
the exhaustion of life yeah yeah if you
call it life is suffering but yeah the
hardship i'm more afraid of hell than
death
you're you're afraid of the thing that
follows
i don't know if it follows or if it's
always here
and i think we're going to find out
what's the connection between death and
hell
i don't know
i don't know
i don't know is there something that
needs to be done before you arrive
you're more likely to die terribly if
you live in a manner that brings you to
hell
that's one connection and terribly it's
as a very deep kind of concept
okay yeah yeah
and that's the definition by the way
what do you make of elon musk you have
spoken about him a bit you might have
struck with admiration
that's what i mean when i was actually
this idea i always think of that as a
primary well it's all it's like do you
find this comedian funny it's like well
i laugh at him
you know what i mean it's not
propositional again
and so
i would there are things i would like to
ask
mr musk about
the mars venture i don't know what he's
up to there it strikes me as absurd in
the most fundamental sense because i
think well it'd be easier just to build
an outpost in the antarctica or in the
desert well how much of the human
endeavor is absurd well
that's what did nietzsche say great men
are seldom credited with their stupidity
who the hell knows what musk is up to i
mean obviously he's building rockets now
he's motivated because he wants to build
a a platform for life on mars is that a
good idea
who am i to say he's he's building the
rockets man but i'd like to ask him
about it i i i would like to see that
conversation i do think
that
having talked to him quite a bit offline
i think these
several of his ideas like mars like
humans becoming a multi-planetary
species could be
one of the things that human
civilization looks back at as
duh
i can't believe he is one of the few
people that was really pushing this idea
because it's the obvious
thing for for society for life to
survive yeah well it isn't obvious to me
that i'm in any position to evaluate
elon musk like i would like to talk to
him and find out what he's up to and why
but
i mean he's an impossible person what
he's done is impossible all of it
it's like he built an electric car that
works now does it work completely and
will it replace gas cars or should it i
don't know but
if we're going to build electric cars he
seems to be the best at that by a lot
and he more or less did that people carp
about him but he more or less did that
by himself i know he's very good at
distributing responsibility and all of
that but he's the spearhead and then
that was pretty hard and then he built a
rocket
at like one-tenth the price of nasa
rockets and then he shot his car out
into space
that's pretty hard and then he's
building this boring
company more or less as a
what would you call it
it's sort of it's this whimsical joke in
some sense but it's not a joke
he's amazing and you're a link delving
into the uh the depths of the mind and
starlink it's like
go elon as far as i'm concerned and then
you know he puts his finger on things so
oddly
the prob the problem is under population
it's like i think so too i think it's a
terrible problem that we're
the west for example is no longer
at
replacement with regard to birth rate it
means we've abandoned the virgin and the
child in a most fundamental sense it's a
bloody catastrophe and musk he sees it
clear as can be it's like wow and where
everyone else is running around going oh
there's too many people it's like
nope
got that not only see i've learned that
there are falsehoods and lies and there
are anti-truths
and an anti-truth is something that's so
preposterous that you couldn't
you couldn't make a claim that's more
opposite to the truth
and the claim that there are too many
people on the planet is an anti-truth
so you know people say well you have to
accept limits to growth and etc it's
like
i have to accept the limits that you're
going to impose on me because you're
frightened of the future
that's your theory is it
okay
well it's an idea it could be a right
idea it could be a wrong idea i don't i
think anti-truth
oh here i'll tell you why it's the wrong
idea i think
so imagine that there's an emergency
dragon
there's a dragon
someone comes and says there's a dragon
i'm the guy to deal with it
that's what the environmentalists say
the radical types who push limits to
growth
then i look at them and i think okay
is that dragon real or not
that's one question well i asked that
question of myself every time when you
spend time alone is the apocalypse
looming on the environmental front yes
or no i'll just leave that aside for the
time being
i think you can make a case both ways
for a bunch of different reasons and
it's not a trivial concern
and we've overfished the oceans terribly
and there are environmental issues that
are looming large
whether climate change is the cardinal
one or not is a whole different question
but we won't get into that that's not
the issue you're clamoring about a
dragon
okay
why should i listen to you
well let's see how you're reacting to
the dragon
first of all you're scared stiff and in
the state of panic
that might indicate you're not the man
for the job
second
you're willing to use compulsion to
harness other people to fight the dragon
for you
so now not only are you terrified
you're a terrified tyrant
so then i would say well then you're not
the moses that we need to lead us out of
this particular exodus
and maybe that's a neurological
explanation it's like if you're so
afraid of what you're facing
that you're terrified into paralysis and
nihilism and that you're willing to use
tyrannical compulsion to get your way
you are not the right leader for the
time
so then i like someone like bjorn
lomberg or matt ridley or marion toopey
and they say well look we've got our
environmental problems
and uh maybe there's a there you could
make a case that there's a malthusian
element in some situations
but fundamentally the track record of
the human race is that we learn very
fast and faster all the time
to do more with less
and we've got this
and i think
yes
to that idea
and i think about it in it
in a fundamental way it's like i trust
lomberg
i trust tupi
trust matt ridley
they thought about these things deeply
they're not just saying oh the
environment doesn't matter whatever the
environment is
you know the environment i don't even
know what that is that's everything the
environment i'm concerned about the
environments like
which is how is that different than
saying i'm worried about everything
how are those statements different
semantically
well yeah the environment it could be
i'm worried about human society a lot of
these complex systems are difficult to
talk about because there's so much
involved for sure yeah everything
and then these models
because people have gone after me
because i don't buy the climate models
well
i think about the climate models as
extended into the economic models
because the climate model is
well there's going to be a certain
degree of heating let's say by 2100 it's
like okay
some of that might be human generated
some of it's a consequence of warming
after the ice age this has happened
before but fair enough let's take your
presumption
although there are multiple presumptions
and any error in your model multiplies
as time extends but to have it your way
okay now we're going to extend the
climate model so to speak into the
economic model so i just did an analysis
of a paper by deloitte
third biggest
company in the u.s
300 000 employees major league
consultants they just produced a report
may i wrote an article for it in the
telegraph which i'm going to release
this week on my youtube channel
said well
if we get the climate problem under
control
economically because that's where the
models are now being generated on the
economic front so now we have to model
the environment
that's climate and we have to model the
economy
and then we have to model their joint
interaction and then we have to predict
100 years into the future
and then we have to put a dollar value
on that
and then we have to claim that we can do
that
which we can't
and then this is our conclusion
we're going to go through a difficult
period of privation
because if we don't accept limits to
growth there's going to be a catastrophe
50 years in the future thereabouts and
so to avert that catastrophe
we are going to make people poorer
now
how much poor well not a lot compared to
how much richer they're going to be but
definitely
and they say this in their own models
definitely poorer definitely poorer
than they would be if we just left them
the hell alone
and so then i think okay
poor array
who
well let's look at it biologically
you've got a hierarchy right of
stability and
security
that's a hierarchy or one type
you stress a hierarchy like that a
social hierarchy so there's birds in a
environment and an avian flu comes in
and then you look at the birds in the
social hierarchy and the
the low ranking birds have the worst
nests so they're most exposed to wind
and rain and sun and farthest from
food supplies and most exposed to
predators and so those birds are
stressed which is what happens to you at
the bottom of a hierarchy you're more
stressed because your life is more
uncertain you're more stressed your
immunological function is compromised
because of that
you're sacrificing the future for the
present
an avian flu comes in and the birds die
from the bottom up
that happens in every epidemic
you die
from the bottom up okay
so they say when the aristocracy catches
a cold
the working class dies of pneumonia all
right so now we're going to make people
poorer
okay who
well we know who we make poor when we
make people poorer
we make those who are barely hanging on
poorer and what does that mean
it means they die
and so what the deloitte consultants are
basically saying is well
you know it's kind of unfortunate
but according to our models
a lot of poor people are going to have
to die
so that a lot more poor people don't die
in the future it's like okay hold on a
sec
which of those two things am i supposed
to regard with certainty
the hypothetical poor people that you're
going to hypothetically save 100 years
from now
or the actual poor people that you are
actually going to kill
in the next 10 years
well i'm gonna cast my law with the
actual poor people that you're actually
going to kill
and so and then i think further it's
like well okay the deloitte consultants
have you actually modeled the world or
is this a big advertising shtick
designed to attract your corporate
clients with demonstration that you're
so intelligent that you can actually
model the entire ecosystem of the world
including the economic system and
predicted a hundred years forward and
isn't there a bit of a moral hazard in
making a claim like that
just like just a trifle especially when
so i talked to bjorn lomberg and michael
leon last week i accepted the un
uh
estimates of starvation this coming year
150 million people will suffer food
insecurity
food insecurity
yeah food insecurity that's the bloody
buzzword
famine
well
michael yawn thought
1.2 billion and then that little spiral
because he said what happens in a famine
is that the governments go nuts crazy
the governments destabilize
and then they appropriate the food from
the farmers
then the farmers don't have any money
then they can't grow crops and i think
yeah that's exactly what they do that's
exactly what would happen
and so
john told me 1.2 billion and then bjorn
lombard said the same thing i didn't
even ask him he just made it as an
offhand comment
so
let me ask you about
the famine of the 30s yeah
do you think ukraine in the ukraine oh
yeah
fun fun fun similar
a lot of the things you mentioned in the
last few sentences kind of echo
to that part of human history the holy
door
do you use no one knows about
well
now i've just spent four weeks in
ukraine oh yeah there's different parts
of the world that still
even if they don't know
they know yeah
right they feel
history is runs in the dutch knew
in some sense they had a famine at the
end of world war ii and part of the
reason the dutch farmers are so
unbelievably efficient and productive
is that the dutch swore at the end of
world war ii that that was not going to
happen again
and then they had to scrape land out of
the ocean
because holland that's quite a country
it shouldn't even exist the fact that
it's the world's number two exporter you
know that's the world's number two
exporter of agriculture products holland
it's like
i don't think it's as big as
massachusetts it's this little tiny
place it shouldn't even exist
and they want to put here's this here's
the plan
let's put 30 percent of the farmers out
of business well the broader ecosystem
of agriculture production in holland is
six percent of their gdp now these
centralizing politicians think
tell me if i'm stupid about this
take an industry
you knock it back
by fiat by thirty percent
now it runs on like a three percent
profit margin now you're going to kill
30 percent of it
how are you not going to bring the whole
thing down the whole farming ecosystem
down
how are you not going to
impoverish the
transport systems how are you not going
to demolish the grocery stores
you can't take something like that and
pair it back by fiat by 30
and not kill it i i can't see how you
can do that i mean look what we did with
the covid lockdowns we broke the supply
chains
tried buying something lately
you can't and wait and aren't the
chinese
threatening taiwan at the moment what
are we gonna do without chips
so
i don't know what these people are
thinking and then i think okay what are
they thinking well the deloitte people
are thinking aren't we smart and
shouldn't we be hired by our corporate
employers it's like okay
too bad about the poor
um what are the uh
environmentalists thinking we love the
planet it's like do you
we love the poor do you okay let's pit
the planet against the poor who wins the
planet okay you don't love the poor that
much do you love the planet
or do you hate capitalism
let's pit those two things against each
other oh well it turns out we actually
hate capitalism how can we tell
because you're willing to break it
and you know what's going to happen so
what's going to happen in sri lanka with
these 20 million people who now have
nothing to eat
are they going to eat all the animals
are they going to burn all the firewood
they're stockpiling firewood in germany
it's like so is your environmental
globalist utopia
going to kill the poor and destroy the
planet and that's okay because we'll
wipe out capitalism it's like okay yeah
the the dragon and the fear of the
dragon drives ideologies some of which
can build a better world some of which
can destroy that world yeah what do you
think of that theory about about
trustworthiness if the dragon that
you're facing turns you into a terrified
tyrant you're not the man for the job
is that a good theory it's an
interesting theory let me use that
theory to challenge because what what
does terror look like
let me
table the turns turn the tables on you
you are
terrified afraid concerned
about the dragon of something we can
call
communism marxism
am i terrified of it well terrific okay
okay a tyrant your theories had two
components yeah
i'm not paralyzed i had a dragon yeah
i'm not paralyzed and i don't want to be
a tyrant
the tyrant part i think is missing with
you
uh so you are very concerned the
intensity of your feeling
uh
does not give much space
actually at least in your public persona
for
sitting quietly with the dragon and
sipping in a couple of beers and
thinking about this thing
the intensity of your anger
concern
about certain things you're seeing in
society
is that going to drive you off the path
that
ultimately takes us to a better world
that's a good question i mean i don't
i'm trying to get that right so
we've kind of come to a cultural
conclusion about the nazis
do you get to be angry about the nazis
seems the answer to that is yes
well actually let me push back here
um i also don't trust people who are
angry about the nazis because i mean the
actual nazis well
i i there's a lot as you know there's a
lot of people in the world
um that
uh
use actual nazis to mean a lot i know i
know one of them is very important to me
for example
yes
he's a nazi i think magical super nazi
as it turns out i i think they actually
sort of steal men all their perspectives
i think a lot of people that call you
nazi mean it
so yeah
so but like that there's an important
thing there though because i i went to
the front in ukraine yeah and a lot of
the people
uh
that lost their home or there kind of
uh that got to interact a lot with
russian soldiers ukrainian people
interact with the russian soldiers
they reported that
the russian soldiers
really believe they're saving
the the people
of ukraine in these local villages from
the nazis
so to them
it's not just that the ukrainian
government has or ukraine has some nazis
it's like
it has been
the idea is that the nazis have taken
over ukraine and we need to free them
this is the belief yeah so this
again nazi's still a dragon that lives
yeah and it's used by people because
it's safe to sit next to that dragon and
spread any kind of ideology you want so
i just want to kind of say that we
um
have agreed on the
on the on on
on this particular dragon but i still
don't trust anybody who uses that yeah
but we have issues with boundaries right
no no it's so this is a very complicated
problem right so renee gerard believed
that
it was a human proclivity to demonize
the scapegoat and then drive it out of
the village and yeah i've thought about
that a lot we need a place to put satan
like seriously this is a serious issue
should he be inside the village or
outside
well maybe he should be inside you
right that's that's the fundamental
essence of the christian doctrine it's
like
satan is best fought on the
battleground of your soul
and that's
that's right
that's right can you actually put words
to the kind of dragon that you're
fighting is it is it is it communism
it's the spirit of cain
yeah
can you elaborate
well what the spirit of cain is
so
adam and eve are thrown out of paradise
for becoming self-conscious or when they
become self-conscious
they're destined to work
and the reason for that as far as i can
tell is that
to become self-conscious is to become
aware of the future that's to become
aware of death that certainly happens in
the adam and eve story to have the
scales fall from your eyes
and then
the consequence of that is that you now
have to labor
to prevent the catastrophes of the
future
that's work work is sacrifice
sacrifice of the present to the future
it's delay of gratification it's
maturity
it's
sacrificed to something as well and in
the spirit of something
okay so now adam and eve
have two children
cain and abel so those are the first two
people in history
because the garden of eden doesn't count
and they're the first two people who are
born rather than created so they're the
first two people and that's a hell of a
story because it's a story of
fratricidal murder that degenerates into
genocide flood and tyranny so
that's fun for the opening salvo of the
story let's say
and abel and cain both make sacrifices
and for some reason abel's sacrifices
please god
it's not exactly clear why
and canes don't
now
there's an
implication in the text that it's
because cain's sacrifices are true or
second rate
god says that abel brings the finest to
the sacrificial altar he doesn't say
that about cain so you can imagine that
cain is sacrificing away but he's he's
holding something in reserve
he's not all in he's not bringing his
best to the table he's not offering his
best to god
and so abel thrives like mad
and everyone loves him and he gets
exactly what he needs and wants exactly
when he needs and wants it he's favored
of god
and cain is bearing this terrible burden
forward and working
and his sacrifices are rejected so
he gets resentful
really resentful
enough
resentful enough to call god out
and say something like
this is quite the
creation you've got going here
i'm breaking myself in half and nothing
good is coming my way
what the hell is up with that and then
there's abel the sun's shining on him
every day
how dare you
it's like okay
but this is god that cain's talking to
and so god says
what cain least wants to hear which is
what god usually says to people he says
look to your own devices
you're not making the sacrifices you
should
and you know it and then he says
something even worse
he says sin
crouch is at your door like a sexually
aroused predatory animal
and you've invited it in
to have your way to have its way with
you
and so he basically says you have
allowed your resentment to preoccupy
yourself
and now you're brooding upon it and
generating something creative new and
awful possessed by the spirit of
resentment
and that's why you're in the miserable
state you're in
so then cain leaves his countenance
falls
as you might expect and cain leaves and
he's so incensed by this because god has
said look
your problems are are of your own making
and not only that you invited them in
and not only that you engaged in this
creatively and not only that you're
blaming it on me and not only that
that's making you jealous of abel who's
your actual idol and goal and cain
instead of changing
kills abel
right
and then cain's descendants are the
first people who make
weapons of war
and so
that's
okay you want to know what i think
that's the eternal story of mankind
and it's playing out right now
except at a thousand times the rate
can i present to you a difficult truth
but not
perhaps not a truth but uh a thought i
have
that it is not always easy to know
which among us are the cane that's for
sure and
resentment
it is um
it is possible to imagine you as the
person
who has a resentment towards
a particular world view
that you really worry about
yeah well i've talked i talked to a good
friend of mine last week about that
publicly we'll release it
so i said well do i have a particular
animus against the left let's say
it's like well probably
okay why well
first of all
i'm a university professor
it's not like the universities are
threatened by the right
they're threatened by the left
100 percent and they're not just
threatened a little bit they're
threatened a lot and that threat made it
impossible for me to continue in my
profession the way i was and it cost me
my clinical practice too and that's not
over yet because i have 10 lawsuits
against me out right now from the
college of psychologists
because they've allowed anyone to
complain about me
anywhere in the world for any reason
and have the choice to follow that up
with an investigation which is a
punishment in and of itself and are
doing so
and then i've been tortured nearly to
death multiple times
by bad actors on the left now i've had
my fair share of radical right wingers
being unhappy with what i've said but
personally
that's been the left the whole time
not only me but my family put it might
put my family at risk in a big way and
constantly like not once or twice
because
many people get cancelled once or twice
but i've been canceled
like 40 times and i know like 200 people
now who've been cancelled and i can tell
you without doubt that it is one of the
worst experiences of their life and
that's if it only happens once
and so
and then i also know that
the communists killed
100 million people in the 20th century
that the intellectuals
excused them for it non-stop and still
haven't quit that almost no one knows
about it and that the specter of
resentful marxism is back in full force
and so do i have a bit of an animus
against that
yes does it go too far
i don't know i'm trying to figure that
out the story you just told
it is seems nearly impossible for you
an intellectual powerhouse not to have a
tremendous amount of resentment
well and this is the so let me challenge
you yeah let me challenge you go right
ahead and challenge you can you steal
man
the
case that
uh the prime minister of this country
trudeau
wants the best for this country and
actually might do good things for this
country as an intellectual challenge
sure
um he seems to get along well with his
wife
he has some kids
there's no sexual scandals and he's in a
position where that could easily be the
case
he seems to have done some good things
on the oceanic management front
he's put a fair bit of canada's oceans
into marine protected areas and that
might be his most fundamental legacy if
it's real
i've been trying to get information
about the actual reality of the
protection and i haven't been able to do
that but that's a good thing so sorry
the family thing is there's something
speaks to his character this is a
character there is some aspect to him
who's that makes him a good man well in
that sense i mean there's the evidence
there you know i mean he's not a jeffrey
epstein profligate on the sexual front
so that's something and
his wife
they seem to have a real marriage and he
has kids so you know good for him that's
a good start by the way for a leader
yeah right to be a great man well then i
also thought okay well after the
liberals had brought in a harvard
intellectual who was a canadian to be
their last leader he didn't work out and
then they're flailing about for a leader
and the liberals in canada are pretty
good at
maintaining
power and leadership and have been the
dominant governing party in canada for a
long time
and so they went to justin
and said
well you know it's you are a
conservative and you can imagine that's
not a positive uh
specter for someone who's on the left
or even a liberal especially trudeau is
quite a bit on the left
and uh they said we need you to run and
then i thought okay well
the answer to that should have been no
because the trudeau justin has no
training for this no experience he's not
he's a part-time drama teacher
fundamentally he hadn't run a business
he just didn't know enough to be prime
minister but then i'm trying to put
myself in this position and so it's like
okay i don't know enough but i'm young
and we don't want the conservatives and
they had had to run a 10-year run so
maybe it was time for new government i
could maybe i could grow into this man
maybe i could surround myself with good
people and i could learn humbly and i
could become
the person i'm now pretending to be
which we all have to do as we move
forward right and so and so then i
thought okay
i think you made a mistake there because
you ran only on your father's name
and you didn't have the background but
let's give the devil as do and say
that's no problem
okay so now what do you do
well you get elected and your first act
is
to make the
cabinet 50 women
despite the fact that only 25 of the
elected
members are female it's like okay you
just have your talent pool
that was a really bad move for your
first movie ask you about that yeah uh
do you think
where does that move come from
deep somewhere in the heart or is it is
it trying to
listen to the social forces that of the
moment and try to ride those
ways towards maybe greater greater
popularity
by after thinking it through it's like
no you just have your talent pool
for cabinet positions that's what you
did there's enough cabinet positions
you know you could argue that each of
the met threshold it's like there's a
big difference between threshold and
excellent so you don't think that that
came from a place of compassion i don't
care i don't regard compassion as a
virtue compassion is a reflex not a
virtue
you don't think judicious compassion is
a virtue wait wait a minute wait a
minute compassion can come deep
from the human heart and the human mind
i think are we talking about the same
kind of compassion yes trying to
understand the suffering treating adults
like infants is not virtuous i i see but
you're you're you well compassion isn't
treating
adults like and i mean it doesn't just
terms are you sure okay
whatever the term is maybe you eat love
love
compassion is
i mean i i suppose i'm speaking to
love you don't think
those ideas came from concern compassion
you don't think love is a blend of
compassion and encouragement and truth
love's complicated man yeah if i love
you
if i love you is it compassion or
encouragement you want from me
yeah the dance love love is definitely a
dance of two to humans ultimately that
leads to the growth of both well that's
the thing the growth element is crucial
yeah
because the growth element to foster the
growth element that requires judgment
compassion and judgment well even
and have been conceptualized this way
forever two hands of god mercy and
justice
they have to operate in tandem right and
mercy is
flawed as you are
you're acceptable
it's like well do you want that do you
want your flaws to be acceptable
and the answer to that is no it's so
it's like well that's where the judgment
comes in it's like
but you could be better you could be
more than you are
and that's the maternal and the paternal
in some fundamental sense
and there has to be a
active
exchange of information between those
two polls
so even if even if trudeau was motivated
by compassion it's like yeah just how
loving are you first of all
no it was a really bad decision and then
he and he's expressed contempt for
monetary policy
i'm not interested in monetary policy
it's like
okay
but you're prime minister
and he's expressed admiration for the
chinese communist party
because they can be very efficient in
their pursuit of environmental goals
it's like oh yeah
efficiency a
the efficiency of the tyranny in the
service of your terror
and so and i've watched him repeatedly
and i've listened to him a lot and i've
tried to do that
clinically and with some degree of
dispassion
and that's hard too because
his father pierre devastated the west
in 1982 with the national energy policy
and
trudeau is doing exactly the same thing
again and so as a westerner as well i
have an inbuilt animus and one that's
well deserved because central canada
especially the glittery literati
elite types in the ottawa montreal
toronto
triangle
have
exploited the west and expressed
contempt for the west far too much for
far too long
and that's accelerating at the moment
for example with trudeau's recent attack
on the canadian farmers he's an enemy of
the oil and
gas industry it's an utter and absolute
bloody catastrophe and look what's
happened in europe
at least in partial consequence and he's
no friend to the farmers
so i've tried to steal manhattan you
know i try to put myself in the position
of the people that i'm criticizing
i think he's a narcissist
do you think there's a degree to which
power changed him
if you're not suited for the position if
you're not the man for the position you
can be absolutely 100 percent sure that
the power will corrupt you how could it
not
i mean at the at the least if you don't
have the chops for the job you have to
devalue the job to the point where you
can feel comfortable inhabiting it
so yes i think that it's corrupted and i
mean look at him doubling down
we wear masks into in flights into
canada
we have to fill out an arrive can
bureaucratic form on our phones because
a passport is good isn't good enough we
can't get a passport
what if you're 85 and you don't know how
to use a smartphone oh well too bad for
you
yeah it's like
yes it's corrupted him would you
talk to him well uh if you were to sit
down and talk with him and he wanted to
talk
uh
would you and what kind of things would
you talk about perhaps on your podcast i
don't think i've ever said no to talking
to anyone
so which is you know would you
would that be a first or would you would
you make that conversation do you
believe in the power no i'd ask him
those kinds of context no if if if he
was willing to talk to me i'd talk
because i'd like to ask him i have lots
of things i'd like to ask him about i
mean i've had political types in canada
on my podcast and tried to ask them
questions
so i'd like to know
is that you know what maybe i've got a
big part of him wrong yes and i probably
do
but
my observation has been that every
chance he had to retreat from his
pharonic position let's say he doubled
down
and
these
our parliament is not running for the
next year
it's still zoom in
it's still covid lockdown parliament
for the next year it's already been
fatally compromised perhaps by the
lockdowns for the last
couple of years
and this is parliament we're talking
about yeah there's a kind of
um paralysis fear-driven paralysis that
also
impart some of the most brilliant people
i know are lost in this paralysis
i don't think people assign a word to it
but it's almost like a fear of this
unknown thing that lurks in the shadows
and that
unfortunately that fear is leveraged by
people
um
that you know who are in in academic
circles who aren't faculty or students
and so on are more administration and
they they start to use that fear which
makes me uh quite uncomfortable it it
does lend people
in the positions of power who are not
good at handling that power to become
slowly
day by day a little bit more corrupt
i was really trying to figure out you
know the last two weeks thinking this
through it's like how do you know
let's say someone asked me a question in
in the youtube comments said why why why
can i trust your advice on the
environmental front
and i thought that's really good
question
okay
let's see if we can figure out the
principles by which the advice would be
trustworthy okay how how do you know
it's not trustworthy
well
one
potential
response to that would be the claims are
not in accordance with the facts but you
know facts are tricky things and it
depends on where you look for them so
that's a tough one to get right because
for example lomberg's fundamental
critics argue about his facts not just
his interpretation of them
so that can't be an unerring guide and
so i thought well the facts exactly
doesn't work
because when it's about everything
there's too many facts
so then how do you determine if
someone's a trustworthy guide in the
face of the apocalyptic unknown because
that's really the question
and the answer is
they're not terrified tyrants
i think that's the answer
now maybe that's wrong if someone has a
better answer how do you know if they're
a terrified tyrant because they're
willing to use compulsion on other
people when they could use goodwill like
the farmers in canada objected they said
look
we have every economic reason to use as
little fertilizer as we can
because it's expensive
we have satellite maps of where we put
the fertilizer we have cut our
fertilizer use
so substantially in the last 40 years
you can't believe it and we grow way
more food we're already breaking
ourselves in half
and if you know farmers especially the
ones who still survive you think you
think those people don't know what
they're doing it's like
they're pretty damn sophisticated man
like
way more sophisticated than our prime
minister
and now you tell them no it's a 30
reduction and we don't care how much
food you're growing so it's not a
reduction
that's
dependent on amount of food produced per
unit of fertilizer used which would be
at least you could imagine it it's okay
so you're producing this much food
and you use this much fertilizer so
you're hyper efficient
maybe we take the 10 of farmers who are
the least efficient in that
metric and we say to them you have to
get as efficient as the average farmer
and then they say well look you know our
our situation is different we're in a
more northern clime the soil is weaker
you know you obviously have to bargain
with that but at least
at least you reward them for their
productivity
well it's like well holland isn't going
to have beef well where are they going
to get it well you don't need it it's
like oh i see you get to tell me what i
can eat now do you
really
okay
and
holland is going to import food
from where that's more efficient on the
fertilizer front
there's no one more efficient than
holland and same with canada
and like isn't this going to make food
prices
more expensive
and
doesn't that mean that hungry people die
because that is what it means
so ultimately poor people pay the price
of these kinds of policies
no not no not ultimately
now today today that's a crucial
distinction because they say well
ultimately the poor will benefit
yeah except the dead ones yes
today today right it seems like the
story of war
too is a time when the poor people
suffer
from the decision made by the powerful
the rich
the uh yeah because the political elite
yeah
let me ask you about the war in ukraine
oh yeah i got into plenty of trouble
about that too
you're
you're just a man in a suit
talking on microphones and writing
brilliant articles
there's also people dying
fighting
it's their land it's their country it's
their history this is true for both
russia and ukraine it's people trying to
ask
they have many dragons and they're
asking themselves the question
who are we what is this
what is the future of this nation we
thought
we are a great nation
and i think both
countries say this and they they say
well how do we become the great nation
we thought we are yeah
and
so what first of all you got in in
trouble
what what's the dynamics of the trouble
and uh well it wasn't regret no saying
no no i thought about it a lot i laid
out four reasons for the war and then i
was criticized in the atlantic for
the argument was reduced to one reason
which was a
caricature of the reason
i gave a variety of reasons why the war
happened mismanagement
on the part of the west in relationship
to russia and foreign policy over the
last since the wall fell
it's understandable because it's
extremely complex
hyper reliance on russia as a
cardinal
source of energy provision for europe in
the wake of idiot environmental
globalist utopianism
the
expansionist tendencies of russia
that are analogous in some sense to the
soviet union empire building and then
the last one which is the one i got in
trouble for which is putin's belief
or willingness to manipulate his people
into believing that russia is a salvific
force
in the face of idiot western wokism and
that's the one i got in trouble for it's
like while you're justifying putin it's
like
it's not only it's not only the russians
that think the west has lost its mind
the eastern europeans think so too and
do i know that it's like
well i went to 15 eastern european
countries this
this spring
and i talked to 300 political and
cultural leaders and you might say well
they were all conservatives like
actually
no they weren't
most of them were conservatives because
it turns out that they're more willing
to talk to me but a good chunk of them
were
liberals by
by any stretch of the
imagination and a fair number of them
were canceled progressives
well because you're very concerned about
um the culture wars that
perhaps are a signal
of a
possible
bad future for this country for this
part of the world that reason stands out
and
do you
sort of looking back at
four reasons think it deserves to have a
place in one of the four
because absolutely because it is you
know uh
well the forum was bifurcated because i
said look putin might believe this and i
actually think he does because i read a
bunch of putin's speeches and i have
been reading them for 15 years and my
sense of people generally and this was
true of hitler it's like
what did hitler believe well did you
read what he wrote
he just did what he said he was going to
do and you might think well some people
are so tricky they have a whole body of
elaborated speech
that's completely separate from their
personality and their personality is
pursuing a different agenda and this
whole body of speech is nothing but a
front
it's like
good luck finding someone that's
sophisticated first of all if you say
things long enough you're going to
believe them that's a really interesting
and fascinating and important point even
if you start out as a as a lie as a
propaganda i think hitler's is an
example of somebody that i think really
quickly you start to believe the
propaganda well
you've thought a lot about ai systems
it's like
don't you become what you practice
and the answer to that is well
absolutely we even know the neurology
it's like when you first formulate a
concept huge swaths of your cortex are
lit up so to speak but as you practice
that
first of all the right hemisphere stops
participating and then the the laugh
participates less and less until you
build specialized machinery for exactly
that conceptual frame and then you start
to see it not just think it
and so if you're telling the same lies
over and over
who do you think you're fooling think
well i can withstand my own lies
not if they're effective lies and if
they're effective enough to fool
millions of people and then they reflect
them back to you what makes you think
you're going to be able to withstand
that
you aren't and so i do think putin
believes
to the degree that he believes anything
i do believe that he thinks of himself
as a bulwark for
christendom
against the degeneration of the west and
that's that third way that dugan and
putin have been talking about the
philosopher alexander dugan and putin
for 15 years now what that is
is very amorphous solzhenitsyn thought
the russians would have to re return to
the incremental development of orthodox
christianity to escape from the
communist trap and to some degree that's
happened in russia because there's been
a return to orthodox christianity now
you could say yeah but the orthodox
church has just been co-opted by the
state and i would say there's some
evidence for that i've heard for example
that the
metropolitan
owns now i don't know if this is true
owns five billion dollars worth of
personal property and i would say
there's a bit of a moral hazard in that
and it's possible that the orthodox
church has been co-opted but there has
been somewhat of an orthodox revival in
russia and i don't think that's all bad
now even if putin doesn't believe any of
this if he's just a psychopathic
manipulator and
unfortunately
i don't think that's true
i've read his speeches it doesn't look
like it to me and he is by no means the
worst russian leader of the last hundred
years
well there's quite a selection there
there certainly is but
and i say that knowing that
even if he doesn't believe it
he's convinced his people that it's true
and so we're stuck with the we're stuck
with the claim
in either case
and that's the point i was trying to
make in the article
sometimes i'm troubled by
people that explain things and i've a
lot of people reached out to me experts
telling me how i should feel
what i should think about ukraine
oh you naive
lex you're so naive you know here's how
it really is
but then i get to see people that
lost their home i get to see people on
the russian side who believe they're
i genuinely think that there's some
degree to which they have love in their
heart
uh they they see themselves as heroes
saving a land from
uh from nazis how else would you
motivate young men to go fight it's just
it's these humans
destroying
not only their homes but creating
generational hate destroying the
possibility of love towards each other
they're they're basically creating hate
what i've heard a lot of is on february
24th this year
hate was born at a scale that region has
not seen
hate towards not vladimir putin hate
towards not the soldiers in russia but
hate towards all russians
hate that will last generations and then
you can
you you could see um um
just
the the pain
there and then then when all these
experts talk about
uh
um
agriculture and energy and geopolitics
and yeah maybe like what you say with
with the
fighting the ideologies of the woke and
so on i just feel like it's missing
something
deep
that war is not fought
about any of those things
war started and wars averted
based on human beings based on well
here's humanity here's another ugly
thought since we haven't had enough so
far
we locked everything down for covid
how much face-to-face communication was
there between the west and vladimir
putin
how about none
how about that was the wrong amount
especially given that europe was
completely dependent on putin for its
energy supplies well not completely but
you know what i mean
materially and significantly so maybe he
had to go talk to him once every six
months maybe he's in a bit of a bubble
probably and not just an information
bubble how all these experts tell me
about yeah no a human human human bubble
look one of the things i've really
learned there's a real emphasis on
hospitality in the old testament
i just brought all these scholars
together to talk about exodus i have
this security team with me and they're
tough military guys
but they're on board for this mission
let's say
and so they went out of their way to be
hospitable to my academic guests they
laid out nice platters of meat and
cheese crackers they spent all day
preparing this house i had rented so
that we could have a hospitable time
with these scholars most of whom i
didn't know well but who said they would
come and spend eight days talking about
this book with me we rented some jet
skis we had a nice house we had fun
and we got to know each other and we got
to trust each other because we could see
that we could have some fun and that we
could let our hair down a bit we didn't
have to be on guard and that made the
talks way deeper and then we found out
we couldn't get through exodus in eight
days and so
i had proposed very early on that we're
going to double the length and so i
pulled eight people out of their lives
for for eight days
that's a that's not an easy thing to do
it's also quite expensive and the daily
wire plus people picked all that up
and they said right they said yes right
away so we'd love to do this again well
why well partly because it was
intellectually it was unbelievably
engaging i learned so much it'll take me
like a year to digest it if i can ever
digest it
and
but
they had they had a really good time
and so when they were offered that
combination of
intellectual challenge let's say in
hospitality it was a no-brainer they
just said every one of them said
if i can do it in any way i will
definitely be there and this whole i
went to washington a bunch of times
and the the culture of hospitality has
broken down in washington 40 percent of
congressmen sleep in their offices
they don't have apartments their family
isn't there with them
they don't
have social occasions with
their fellow democrats or republicans
much less across the table
and so and i tried to have some meetings
in washington that were bilateral a
couple of times get young republican
congressmen and democrats together to
talk and as soon as they talk they think
oh
it was so interesting because one of the
lunches was about
15 people half democrats and half
republicans and all i'd asked them to do
was just spend three minutes talk about
why you decided to become a congressman
which is not a job i would take by the
way
you spend 25 hours a week fundraising on
the telephone
your family isn't there with you
you have to run for election every two
years you're beholden to the party
apparatus
right you're vilified constantly this is
not you know people think well this is a
job for the privileged it's like yeah
you go and run for congress and find out
how much fun it is and put your family
on the line and then have to beg for
your job every two years well your
enemies the worst of your enemies are
the and the worst of your friends are
viciously hen pecking you
and so anyways we had them all sit
around the table said okay just say why
you
ran for congress it was so cool
especially for a canadian because you
americans you're so bloody theatrical
it's such something to watch
it was like mr smith goes to washington
for every one of them it's like well
this country has given us so much where
families have been so
so uh we've benefited so much from our
from our time here we think this is a
wonderful country we really felt that we
should give back
then the next one would talk and it was
like exactly the same story and then it
didn't matter if they were republican or
democrat you couldn't tell the
difference no one could and was it
genuine it's like well are you genuine
you think these people are worse than
you
first of all they're not
second of all they're probably better
all things considered it's not that easy
to become a congressman and i'm sure
there's some bad apples in the bunch but
by and large you walk away from your
meetings with these people and you think
pretty impressive they really are giving
a part of themselves in in the name of
service maybe over time they become
cynical and become
jaded and worn down by the whole system
but i think a lot of it could you
imagine that
is healed i think
and i don't think i'm
well i'm in part naive but not fully
that a lot of it is healed through the
power of conversation just basic social
interaction
i do think that the batman the effects
of this pandemic by listening
look listen just sitting there and it
doesn't have to be talking about the
actual issue it's actually
humor and all those kinds of things uh
about personal struggles all those kinds
of things that remind you that you're
all just humans yeah well the great
leaders that i've met because and i've
met some now
they go listen to their constituents
it's not a policy discussion it's not an
ideology discussion they go say okay
what's what's your what's your life like
and what are your problems and
tell me about them and then they listen
and then they're struck by them and then
they gather up all that misery and they
bring it to the congressional office or
to the parliament and they think
here's what the people are crying out
for
and the good leaders
that's a leader
leader listens
it's like i talked to jimmy carr
about comedy
and he's sold out
stages worldwide on a tour being funny
that's hard
he said
comedy is the most stand-up comedy
which is what i do in some real sense
it's a thing i do that it's most akin to
what i'm doing on my book tours i would
say it's the closest analog
he said it's the most dialogical
enterprise and i thought well
why what do you mean because see it's
just a monologue and it's a prepared
monologue i mean you have to
interact dynamically with the audience
while you're telling your jokes and
you've got to get the timing right but
you have a body of jokes
i said well here's how you prepare the
jokes
and i've been told this by other
comedians you go to 50 clubs before you
go on your tour
and you got some new material and you
think it's funny
and you go into a club and
you lay out your new material and people
laugh at some of it
and you pay attention
to what they laugh at and what they
don't laugh at
so you subject yourself to the judgment
of the crowd and you get rid of
everything that isn't funny
and if you do that enough even if you're
not that funny
the crowd will tell you what's funny so
you can imagine imagine you do 50 shows
and each is an hour long and you collect
two minutes of humor from each show so
you throw away 90 you throw away
two hours more than 98 of it
collect two minutes per show
so you're not very funny at all you're
like funny two percent of the time you
aggregate that man you're a scream
so so that's what a leader does is that
is what leader does it goes out and he
aggregates the misery you know and the
hopes
and then i do think that's revivifying
to someone who would otherwise be
cynical and jaded because then the
person can say to themselves
despite the inadequacies of the system
and my inadequacies
i'm
i'm gathering up the misery and and the
hope and i'm
bringing it forward where it can be
redressed giving it a voice giving
that's right giving it a voice can you
actually take me through a day because
this is fascinating um through your
comedy tour
uh what is a day in the life of jordan
peterson look like
which is this very interesting day let's
look at the day when you have to speak
preparing your mind thinking of what
you're going to talk about
preparing yourself physically
mentally to interact with the crowd
through the actual speaking how do you
adjust what you're thinking through and
how do you come down from that so you
can start all again as a limited
system
well
i'm usually up by
seven
and ready to go by
7 30 or 8.
coffee
no no steak and water how many times a
day steak
oh that's all i eat how many times
three or four depending on the day steak
and water taking sparkling water
yeah so
monastic asceticism man well i did the
proper i i usually just once a day i did
the the proper jordan peterson last
night and just ate two steaks and how
was that it was wonderful
yeah well if you have to only eat one
thing
you know could be worse so anyways i'm
ready to go at eight because we're
generally moving
what does it moving mean
you're constantly flying somewhere okay
and we usually use private flights now
because the commercial airlines aren't
reliable enough and you cannot not make
a venue right so that's rule number one
on the tour
you make the show
so everything and then number rule
number two is anybody who causes any
trouble on the tour is gone
because there is zero room for error now
no there's zero room for unnecessary
unaddressed error so because there's
going to be errors the guys i have
around me now
if they make a mistake they fix it right
away yeah so
and that's great there's a lot of people
relying on you to be there so you have
like like
4 000 people typically yeah so so then
i'm on the plane
and i'm usually i usually write
or often
because there's no
internet on the plane and that's a good
use of time so i'm writing a new book so
i write on the plane typing or
handwriting typing
yeah typing
and uh
then we land and we go to
it's usually
early afternoon by then we go to a hotel
it's usually a nice hotel that's not
corporate i don't really like corporate
hotels my secretary and my one of my
logistics guys has got quite good at
picking
kind of adventurous hotels boutique
hotels are usually in the old parts of
the city especially in europe somewhere
interesting and so we go there
and then
lunch usually and sometimes that's an
air fryer and a steak in the hotel room
and i leave a trail of airfryers behind
me all across the world
and
then
tammy and i usually go out and have a
walk or something and take a look at the
city and then i have a rest for like an
hour and a half or an hour half an hour
like a nap yes now i have to sleep for
20 minutes and that's about all i can
say but i need to do that in the late
hour it never refreshes your mind yeah
that gives me that wakes me up again for
the evening
and then tam has to sleep longer she's
still recovering from her illness and so
she has to sleep longer in the afternoon
and that's absolutely necessary for both
of us or things start to get frayed
and so then
we go to the venue
and then i usually sit for
an hour
if i'm gonna lecture i've been doing a
lot of q and a's and that's a little
easier but if i'm gonna lecture i have
to sit for an hour and then i think okay
what question am i trying to investigate
i have to have that that's the point
what mystery am i trying to
unravel it's usually associated with one
of the rules in my book because
technically it's a book tour but each of
those rules is an investigation into an
ethic
and each of them points to a deeper sort
of mystery in some sense and
there's no end to the amount it can be
explored
and so i have the question
the question might be something like uh
put your
put your house in perfect order before
you criticize the world okay
what does that mean exactly put what
does house mean
what does put
what does put mean that active
verb what does perfect and order mean
why before you criticize the world what
does it mean to criticize what does it
mean to criticize the world how can you
do that properly or improperly so i
start to think about how to decompose
the question and you start to think
which of these decompositions are
important to really dig into yeah well
then they'll strike me it's like okay
there's something there that that i've
been maybe noodling around on that i
would like to investigate further then i
think okay how can i approach this
problem i think well i have this story
that i know i have this story and i have
this story but i haven't juxtaposed them
before and there's going to be some
interesting interaction in the
juxtaposition so i have the question and
i kind of have a framework of
interpretation and then i have some
potential narrative places i can go and
then i think okay i can go juggle that
and see what happens
and so then what i want to do is
concentrate on that process while
attending to the audience to make sure
that the words are landing
and then see if i can delve into it
deeply enough so that a narrative
emerges spontaneously
with an ending now i'm sure you've
experienced this in podcasts right
maybe i'm wrong but my experience has
been
if i fall into the conversation
and we know about the time frame
there'll be a natural narrative arc
and then so you'll kind of know when the
midpoint is and you'll kind of see when
you're reaching a conclusion and then if
you really pay attention you can see
that's a good place to stop
it's kind of you come to a point
and
you have to be alert and patient to see
that
and you have to be willing to be
satisfied with where you've got to
but if you do that and then it's like a
comedian making the
punch line work it's like
i've got all these balls in the air
and they're going somewhere
and this is
how they come together and people love
that right they say oh this and this
this and this
whack
together
and that's an insight and it is very
much like a punchline well that's
interesting because your mind actually
some i'm a fan of your podcast too and
you are always driving towards that i
would say
for me in in a podcast conversation
there's often a kind of
alice in wonderland type of exploration
down the rabbit hole man and then you
just a new thing pops up and the more
absurd the wilder the better yeah
conversations with elon are like this
yeah it's like actually the more you
drive towards an ark the more
uncomfortable you start to get
in
a fun absurd conversation because
oh i i'm now one of the normies no i
don't want that i want to be i want i
want the rabbit i want the crazy
because it makes it more uh
fun but somehow
throughout it there is
wisdom you try to grasp at well such
that there is a thread well that's the
thing man you're following the thread eh
yeah the thread's right the thread well
that's right that's what we're trying to
do that thread
that thread is the proper balance
between structure and spontaneity and it
manifests itself as the instinctive
meaning and that's the logos in the
dialogues and it really is the logos and
god only knows what that means
you know i mean the biblical claim is
that logos is the fundamental principle
of reality
and i think that's true
i actually think that's true
because i think that that meaning that
guides you well here's a way of thinking
about i've been writing about this
recently
what's real
matter it's like okay that's one answer
what's real
what matters is real
because that's how you act
okay that's different than matter
it's like okay
what's the most real of what matters
how about pain
why is it the most real
try arguing it away
good luck
so pain is the fundamental reality
all right
well that's rough
doesn't that lead to nihilism and
hopelessness
yeah doesn't it lead to a philosophy
that's antithetical towards being the
most fundamental reality is pain
yes
is there anything more fundamental than
pain
love
really
if you're in pain
love and truth
that's what you got
and you
know if they're more powerful than pain
maybe they're the most real things
when you think about reality what is
real that is the most real thing
well it's a tough one right because you
have to
because if you're a scientist a
materialist think well
the matter is the most real it's like
well you don't know what the matter is
yeah and so and then when push comes to
shove and it will
you'll find out what's most real yeah
i i feel like this is uh
missing
physical reality is is missing some of
the things
so of course pain has a biological
component and all those kinds of things
but it it's missing something deep about
the human condition that
at least the modern science is not able
to
uh describe but it is reaching towards
that yeah it is the reason
one way to describe it as you're
describing is the reason it's reaching
it is because underneath of science is
this assumption that
there's a deep
logos
thing to this whole thing we're trying
to do
well you know there's two traditions
right in some sense there's two logos
traditions
there's the
the greek
rational
enlightenment tradition that's a logos
tradition and it insists that there's a
logos in nature and that science is the
way to approach it and then there's the
judeo-christian logos which is more
embodied and more spiritual and i would
say the west is actually an attempt to
unite those two
and it's the proper attempt to unite
those two
because they need to be united
and i see the union coming in near terms
you know i talk to friends to wall for
example about the animating principle of
chimpanzee sovereignty
and that's pretty close biologically is
it power
because that's the claim even from the
biologists often the most dominant chimp
has the best reproductive success
it's like
oh yeah
dominant eh you mean using compulsion
okay let's look are the chimps who use
compulsion
the most successful
and the answer is
sporadically and rarely
and for short well that's sporadically
for short periods of time why because
they meet an unpleasant end
the subordinates over whom they exercise
arbitrary control
wait for a weak moment and then tear
them into shreds
right
every dictator's terror
and for good reason and dewall has
showed that the alpha chimps the males
who do have preferential mating access
often
are often
and reliably
the best peacemakers and the most
reciprocal
and so even among chimps the principle
of sovereignty is something like
iterative iterated
reciprocity
and that's a way better principle than
power
and it's something like i've been
thinking what's the antithesis of the
spirit of power
i think it's the spirit of play
and you know you i don't know what you
think about that but when you have a
good podcast conversation you already
described it in some sense as play it's
like there's a structure right because
it's an ordered conversation but you
want there to be play in the system and
if you get that right then it's really
engaging and then it seems to have its
own
narrative arc i'm not trying to impose
that even though that's another thing i
don't do i didn't come to this
conversation
at all thinking here's what i want out
of a conversation with lex friedman like
instrumentally i thought
i'll go talk to lex why
i like his podcasts
he's doing something right i don't know
what it is he asks interesting questions
i'll go have a conversation with him
where's it gonna go
wherever it goes
embracing the spirit of play
so what you have this
when you're lecturing
you're going in front of the crowd
you thought of a question yeah just you
get on the stage first of all are you
nervous at all
i'm very nervous when i'm sitting down
thinking through the structure
initially which is why my wife and i
have been doing q and a's and that's
easier on me yeah it's the uh
it's the the way comedians are nervous
like uh joe rogan just did his special
so this weekend and so he now has to sit
nervously like a comedian does which is
like
i have no material now
right i have to start from scratch when
i was doing the lectures constantly
instead of the q and a's
basically what i was doing was writing a
whole book chapter every night
and you know now that's a bit of an
exaggeration because i would return to
themes that i had developed but it's not
really an exaggeration because i didn't
ever
just
go over rote material ever
so it was it's very demanding and that
part's nerve-wracking because i sit down
it's an hour before the show and i think
can i pull can i do this
and you know the answer is well you did
it
a thousand times
but that's not this time yeah it's like
can i come up with a question can i
think through the structure can i pull
off the
spontaneous
narrative can i pull it together and the
answer is i don't know and so then i get
it together in my mind i think and
that's hard it takes effort and it's
nerve-racking
okay i got it but then there's the
moment you go out on stage and you think
well i know i had it but can i do it no
notes
and then the question is well you're
going to find out well you do it
and so then i go out on stage
and i don't talk to the audience
i talk to one person at a time
and you can talk to one person you know
because you know how to do that so i
talk to a person and not too long
because i don't want to make them too
nervous and then someone else and
someone else and then i'm in contact
with the audience and then i can tell
if the words are landing and i listen
it's like are they rustling around
are they dead quiet because they want
dead quiet you're so i see because
that's what focus sounds like
you're you're in it together then you
bet well and i also here's a good rule
if you're learning to speak publicly i
never say a word
till everyone is 100
quiet
and that's it's a great way to start a
talk because
you're set in the frame and if the frame
is we'll all talk while you're talking
the message is
well you can talk
this is a place where everybody can talk
it's like no it's not
this is a place where people paid to
hear me talk
so i'm not going to talk till everyone's
listening and so then you get that
stillness
and then you just wait because that
stillness turns into an expectation and
then it comes turns into a kind of
nervous expectations like what the hell
is he doing it's not manipulative it's a
sense of timing it's like just when
that's right you think okay now it's
time to start well that nerve the
interesting thing about that nervous
expectation is from an audience
perspective we're in it together
yeah i mean there is into that silence
there's a togetherness to it of course
it's the union of everyone's attention
yeah yeah and that's
and that's a great thing i mean you love
that at a concert when everyone it's not
silenced then but when everyone's
attention is unified and everyone's
moving in unison it's like we're all
worshiping the same thing
right it's when that would be the point
of the conversation the point of the
lecture and the worship is the direction
of attention towards it and it's uni
it's communion because everyone's doing
it at the same time
and so
i mean there's not much difference
between lecture theater and a church in
that regard right it's the same
fundamental layout and structure and
they're very integrally associated with
one another one really grew out of the
other the lecture theater grew out of
the church so it's it's perfectly
reasonable to be thinking about it in
those terms
and so and then okay so after
the lecture
we play a piece of music that is a piece
of music that i've been producing with
some musicians for
a couple of books i'm going to release
in the fall terrible books abc of
childhood tragedy they're called dark
dark books
dark and
comical books
terrible books
heartbreaking illustrations
we've set them to music and so we play a
piece from that and then afterwards i
usually meet about 150 people
to have photographs and
so each of those is a little is there a
little sparkle of human connection a lot
a lot it's it's very intense
10 seconds with every person you think
how can 10 seconds be intense it's like
pay enough attention it gets intense
real quick does it break your heart to
say goodbye so many times
it's like being at a in a wedding lineup
at a wedding that you want to be at
and everybody's dressed up and that's so
weird because i bought these expensive
suits when i went on tour and it broke
my heart because i spent so much money
on them i thought god that's completely
unconscionable i thought no way man
yeah i'm in this 100
and so i'm gonna dress with respect
and
like sixty percent of the audience comes
in two or three-piece suits they're all
dressed up
then there's this line to greet me and
they're all happy to see me
that's not so hard to take you know
although it is in a sense right because
normal interactions are pretty shallow
and you think i don't want shallow
interactions like yes you do most of the
time yeah it's intense it's very intense
and i don't know if you but you've had a
taste of this no doubt because people
recognize yeah but i also have um when a
person recognizes me and they come with
love and they're often
brilliant people
one of the thoughts i have to deal with
one of the dragons in my own mind is
you know thinking that i don't deserve
that kind of attention
and so well you probably don't
right
so
it's a burden in that i have to step up
to be the kind of person that deserves
that that deserves that but in part
deserves that kind of intention and
that's like
holy [ __ ] it's crucially important too
because if someone comes up to you in an
airport and they know who you are and
they're
brave enough to admire you or who you
are attempting to be and you
make a mistake
they will never
forget it yeah so it's a high-stakes
enterprise and the flip side of that
especially with young people
a few words you can say can change the
direction of their life one way or
another
and so i really have to watch this too
in airports i do not like airports i do
not like the creeping totalitarianism in
airports they've always bothered me yes
they really bother me
and i'm an unpleasant travel companion
for my wife sometimes because of that
although i think we've worked that out
thank god because we're doing a lot of
traveling
but
most of the security guards and and the
border personnel all those people they
know me and as a general rule they're
positively predisposed to me and so if
i'm peevish or irritable
yeah then
well that's not good
it's not good and so that's a tight rope
to walk to because i do not like that
creeping totalitarianism but by the same
token
you know
if you're just one of the crowd just
you know sometimes you it's good just to
be one of the crowd and then you're a
little irritable and people can just
brush that off but if you're someone
they have dared to open their heart to
because that's what admiration is and
then you're
be and you betray that then
that's a real
they'll never forget it and then they'll
tell everyone too
so
it takes a lot of alertness and so tammy
in our life has got complicated because
in toronto for example
we can't really just go for a walk
it's always a high drama production
because always people come up and they
have some
heart-rending story to tell and i'm not
being cynical about that yes
it's a hard thing to
bear because people don't do that they
don't just open themselves up to you
like that and share the tragedy of their
life
but that's an everyday occurrence
and so when we go up to our cottage
which is out of the city
it's a relief you know because
as wonderful as that is like it's a
weird i have a weird life because
everywhere i go it's very weird it's
like i'm surrounded by old friends
because i walk down the street in any
city now virtually and people say hello
dr peterson so nice to see you or they
say better things than that very rarely
bad things
one
one experience in 5000 may be very rare
although you don't forget those either
but it's very it's very strange
so and there's an intimacy they know you
well and and because they leap into
uh they avoid the small talk often they
leap into familiarity it really is like
it's an old friend and it feels like
that for me personally the experience is
the goodbye hurts
because um
you know there's a sense where you're
never going to see that friend again
right
yeah that's a strange thing eh so to me
a lot of the uh
a lot of it just feels like goodbyes
mm-hmm
well it is
you're right about that and i mean
that's i suppose in some sense
part of the pain of opening yourself up
to people because they also
tammy has been struck particularly she
said i really never knew what men were
like i said what do you mean
she said i cannot believe how polite
the men are when they come and talk to
you
because it's always the same the
pattern's very similar
the person comes up they're mostly men
not always but mostly
and they're tentative and they're very
polite very very polite and they say i
hope i'm not bothering you do you mind
you know do you mind that i say that
they're not bothering me
and i'm doing everything i can to not be
the guy who's bothered by that it's like
who do you think you are yeah
yes you're the guy that
what is famous and now is above that
yeah
you don't want to be that guy yeah so
you want to be grateful all the time
when people open up like that
and
and so you got to be alert and on point
to do that properly like right away
because
for these for you it's 5 seconds or 10
seconds or 20 seconds whatever it is but
for them
they've opened up and so you can really
nail them if you're
foolish
after the 150 people how do you come
down from that how do you
how do you find yourself again
well that was when i got taught caught
in twitter traps you know because i'm so
burnt out by then
from the from the talk and the
and the audience interactions and the
whole day because it's a new city it's a
new hotel it's it's a new 5 000 people
it's a new book chapter it's a whole new
horizon of ideas and it's off to another
city the next day
i'm so burnt out by then that
i'm not as good at
controlling my impulses as i might be
and twitter was a real catastrophe for
that because it would hook me and then i
couldn't
like i used to when i was working on my
book
a lot i used to call tammy and say look
you have to come and get me i can't stop
i can't stop i got tired and then i kind
of because it's part of a kind of hype
hypomanic focus i couldn't quit it's
like oh no i i'm still writing i need to
get away from this but i couldn't stop
and so
it's better to
to read something
a book
fiction nonfiction fiction
stephen king i was reading a lot of
stephen king when i was on tour last
time that was good i like stephen king a
lot great narratives great and great
characterization
you know
so and
there's a familiarity about stephen
king's
writing too that it's he writes about
people you know
and so i really found that a relief
and so that was useful
and that in order to tolerate this let's
say or to be able to sustain it
well let's take a lot of negotiation on
the part of tammy and i because
she's dragged into this and
you know her life is
part of this whatever this is and she's
had to find her way and has for example
now she has a different hotel room than
me when we travel
and she she found that she didn't want
to be on the tour this spring and i was
ill again for part of it not made it
complicated but she went away back home
and she came back and she said and she
was nervous but she said i think i need
my own room and part of me was not happy
with that it's like what do you mean you
need your like are we not married
anymore it's like you need your own room
and she said well you know i can't she
has to do exercises because she was
really sick and she has to keep herself
in shape
and she has to have some time to do that
she does a lot of prayer and meditation
and she needs the time and she has her
own podcast which is going quite well
and she needs the time and
and i trust her and she said well i need
this
in order to continue and i thought well
okay
like if you need this in order to
continue
yes
because she went away and didn't say
well i i don't want to be on the tour i
don't want to do this anymore she went
away and prayed let's say
how can i continue to do this
and that was the answer and so she has
her own hotel room
and
that was a really good decision on her
part and she's very good
and getting better all the time at
figuring out
what has to happen for her to make this
sustainable and all that's been is a
plus
because
i don't want to travel without her and
and i don't want her life to be
miserable and i want her to be fully on
board and so she has to be properly
selfish
like everyone does in a relationship and
you have to
not just say yes this is a weird thing
that you're doing and you have to
both you and her have to figure out how
to like
how to manage this very intense
intellectual well
there's another element to it too that i
didn't tell you about so that was a
typical day but it's missing a big
component because usually we also have a
dinner
with like 30
cultural representatives i suppose
10 to 30 from each country because i
have a network of people who have
networks who are setting me up with key
decision
makers in each country and so then we
have like an hour and a half of that now
sometimes that's on a day when i don't
have a talk if we but sometimes the
talks are back to back
and so she also has to
manage that and to be gracious and and
then people are showing us exciting
things and tours in the cities and which
is all like it's a surf fight of
wonderful yes exactly but you're it's
still yeah you have to be there for you
have to be present for it mentally yeah
as a curious mind as an intellectual
mind how do you uh how do you get to
sleep
fortunately
that is almost never a problem even when
i was
unbelievably ill
for about three years
i thought about that a lot too you know
that i didn't do a really good job of
explaining that while i was ill because
it appeared in some sense that the
reason i was ill was because i was
taking benzodiazepines but that isn't
why
i was ill and then i took them and very
low dose and i took that for a long time
and it helped whatever was wrong with me
and it looks like it was an allergy or
maybe multiple
allergies and then
that stopped working and so i took a
little bit more for about a month and
that made it way worse and so then i cut
back a lot and then
then things really got out of hand and
so so there was a deeper thing
oh yeah
oh yeah what can you put words to
well i had a lot of immune my my
daughter as everyone knows has a very
reactive immune system and tammy has
three immunological conditions each of
them quite serious and i had psoriasis
and peripheral uveitis which is an
autoimmune condition and alopecia areata
and
chronic gum disease all of which
appeared to be elderly related and so
michaela seems to have got all of that
and so that and that i think was at the
bottom of because i also had this
proclivity to depression that was part
of my family history but i think that
was all immunological as far as i can
tell so one of the things that's
happened to me
i always noticed i really couldn't
breathe
like i could breathe about one-fifth as
much as i
sometimes could
and so i was always short of breath and
it looks like what that was perhaps was
i was always on the border of an
anaphylactic reaction
which is not pleasant
and that's hyper sympathetic activation
no parasympathetic activation i couldn't
relax
at all that's an immunological response
allergic response yeah
so anyways that was what seemed now this
i don't like to talk about this much
because it's so bloody radical and you
know i don't like to propagate it but
this diet seems to have stopped all of
that i don't have psoriasis all of the
patches have gone yeah
my gum disease which is incurable i had
multiple surgeries to deal with it it's
completely gone took three years my
right eye which was quite cloudy it's
cleared up completely
[Music]
what else has changed well i lost 50
pounds and like instantly kept it off i
should mention that i i too am not a
deep investigator of nutritional science
i have my skepticism towards the degree
to which it is currently the science
because like a lot of complex systems is
various full of mystery
uh and full of uh
profiteers the people that profit of
different kinds of diets but i should
say for me personally it does seem that
i feel
by far the best when i eat only meat
that's very interesting and i discovered
that
a long time ago first of all how do you
discover it uh so by
the discovery went like this i started
listening to ultra marathon runners
about
15 years ago
and they started talking about
fat
adapted running
so i first discovered that i don't have
to run super fast to enjoy running and
in fact i really enjoy running at a
slower pace
so that was like step one it's like oh
okay if i maintain
something called uh
the math rule which is a pretty low
heart rate if i maintain that you can
actually get pretty fast while
maintaining a pretty slow average speed
in general anyway they fuel themselves
on
low carb diets
so i got into that
on top of that i also they also fast
often so i discovered how incredible my
mind feels
when fasted you know people call it
intermittent fasting but well that's an
optimization of death eh because
you're when you fast your body
logically and obviously if you think
about it biologically is well what does
your body scavenge first well
damaged tissue
so
the
the
i know the literature on fasting to some
degree and it's it's very compelling
literature if you if you starve dogs
down i think it's 20 below rats too
below their optimal body weight they
live 30 percent longer
yeah
that's a lot thirty percent like it's
like thirty percent yeah yeah thirty
percent well there there is aspect to a
lot of these things that make me nervous
because it's i always feel like there's
no free lunch that i'm gonna pay for it
somehow but there is a focus that i am
able to attain when i fast
especially when i eat once a day
my mind is almost like nervously focused
it's almost like an anxiety but a
positive one or one that i can channel
into just like an excitement you know i
wonder how much of that's associated
with
well imagine that
that signifies lack of food which not
that hard to imagine well maybe you
should be a lot more alert in that
situation right biologically speaking
because you're in hunting mode let's say
you know not desperate but in hunting
mode and god only knows
maybe human beings should be in hunting
mode all the time often but that we
don't know that so i wonder if it has
a stress on the system that long term
causes the system doesn't it doesn't
look like it it it seems in case of
fasting not and then on top of that i
discovered that the thing i enjoy i just
don't enjoy eating
fat
as much so i love eating meat and when
you talk about low carb diets so i just
discovered through that process if
someone fatted me but just me
i just feel
a lot of the things that make me feel
weird about food like a little groggy or
like full or just
whatever
the aspects of food that i don't enjoy
they're not there with meat and i'm
still able to enjoy company and when i
eat once a day
and eat meat
at least in texas
you could still have all the merriment
oh yeah you have dinner with friends now
i don't do the uh this you know you have
a very serious thing
that
um
there's health benefits that you are
very serious about for me i can still
drink whiskey
i'll still do the things that add a
little bit of uh spice spice into the
thing yeah now when you completely
remove the spice it it does become more
difficult yeah it's more difficult
socially and tami seems to only be able
to eat lamb although she might be able
to eat non-aged beef and that makes
traveling complicated too right because
well for obvious reasons it's like
really that's all you can eat
yeah well c'est la vie and maybe that's
a form of craziness but
if it can return to actually the thing
you were talking about
when you're thinking about a question
before the lecture yeah let me ask you
about thinking in general
um
this is something maybe that you and jim
keller
think a lot about is thinking how to
think um
how do you think
through an idea well first of all i i
think okay
that's a really good question
we tried to work that out with this
essay app that my son and i have
developed because if you're going to
write the first question is well what
should i write about
what's the name of the app sa.app
and
well the first question is
well what bugs you
what's bugging you
this is such a cool thing it's like
where is my destiny
well what bothers you well that's where
your destiny is your destiny is to be
found in what bothers you
why do those things bother you there's a
lot of things you could be bothered by
like a million things man but some
things grip you
they bug you and they might make you
resentful and bitter because they bug
you so much like they're your things man
they've got you
so then
i look for a question that i would like
the answer to
that i don't and i would really like the
answer to it
so i don't assume i already have the
answer because i would actually really
like to have the answer
so if i could get a better answer great
and so that's the first thing and that's
like a prayer it's like okay
here's a mystery i would like
to
delve into it further
well so that's humility it's like here's
a mystery
which means i don't know i would like to
delve into it further which means i
don't know enough already
and then
then comes the revelation
it's like
well what's a revelation well if you ask
yourself a question
it's a real question
do you get an answer or not
the answer is well yeah thoughts start
to appear in your head
so from somewhere that's right from
somewhere where do they come from do you
have a sense
depends on what you're aiming at
depends on the question but no no it
don't it does to some degree
it depends it depends on your intent
so imagine that
your intent is to make things better
then maybe they come from the place
that's designed to make things better
maybe your intent is to make things
worse
then they come from hell
and you think not really it's like
you're so sure about that are you is
your intent conscious like are you able
um
conscious and habitual right because as
you practice something consciously it
becomes habitual but it's conscious it's
like i when i sit down
before i do a lecture i think okay
what's the goal here to do the best job
i can
to what end well people are coming here
not for political issues they're coming
here because they're trying to make
their lives better okay so what are we
doing we're conducting a joint
investigation into the nature of that
which makes life better okay what's my
role to do as good a job about that as
possible what state of mind do i have to
be in am i annoyed about the theater
or am i do am i clued in and thrilled
that 4 000 people have showed up at
substantial expense and trouble to come
and listen to me talk
and if i'm not in that state of mind i
think well maybe i need something to eat
or maybe i need to talk to someone
because
that
ingratitude is no place to start it's
like i should be thrilled to be there
obviously and so that that orientation
has to be there and then i said
conscious all this is conscious what am
i serving the highest good i can
conceptualize what is that i have some
sense but i don't know it in the final
analysis which is why the investigation
is being conducted who's doing it me
whoever i'm communing with and the
audience
and so i want i try to get myself and i
chase everybody away for that it's like
i have to do that by myself are you
writing stuff down
yes at that point i make no i just make
point notes and it's usually about maybe
30 notes but then i on stage i never
refer to them and i often don't even use
the structure that i laid out
kind of an interesting thing from where
do powerful phrases come from do you
have a do you have a
do you try to encapsulate an idea into a
sentence or two
well i
when i talk i practice this since
consciously since 1985
i try to feel
and see
if the words are stepping stones or
foundation stones right it's like is
this solid is this word solid is this
phrase solid is this sentence solid like
it's a real sense of
fundamental foundation under each word
and i suppose people ask me if i pray
and i would say i pray before every word
well when you're when you're asking
questions like you're very
clear
headed
and present in your
ability to ask questions and inquire so
how do you do that
so first of all
i'm worried that
my mind easily gets trapped
when i step on a word and i know
it's unstable
you kind of realize that you don't
really know the definitions of any words
you use
and that can be
debilitating
so i kind of try to be more carefree
about the words i use
because otherwise you get trapped you
don't want to be obsessional
like literally my mind halfway through
the sentence will think
well
what does the word sentence mean right
right right well you know
everything else just explodes your big
picture idea explodes and you lost
yourself in the minutia well
neurologically
there's a production center
and an editing center
and those can be separately affected by
strokes
and so
often when people are writing or talking
they try to activate both at the same
time and that's so people will try to
write an essay and get every sentence
right the first draft that's a big
mistake and so then you might say well
how can you be careful with your words
but carefree and the answer is
orient yourself properly right while in
the conversation we're having you you
have an orientation structure you want
to
be prepared you want to be attentive
then you want to have an interesting
conversation
and you want to have the kind of
interesting conversation that other
people want to listen to
that will be good for them in some
manner
okay so that's pretty good frame
and and then you kind of scour your
heart and you think is that really what
you want are you after fame or after
notoriety are you after money i'm not
saying any of those things are
necessarily bad
but
they're not optimal especially if you're
not willing to admit them right and so
they can contaminate you so you want to
be decontaminated so you have the right
trip
let's say
and
and so you have to put yourself that's a
meditative practice you have to put
yourself in the right receptive position
with the right goal in mind then
you can
and i think you can get better and
better at this then you can trust
what's going to happen
you know so for example before i came
here
i i mean i presume you have a reason for
doing the podcast
with me
what's the reason
um
i mean we
wanted to talk for a long time so the
reason has evolved
the
one of
the reasons is i've listened to you
uh for quite a long time so you become a
one-way friend
and i have many one-way friends some of
my best friends don't even know i exist
so i'm a big fan of podcasts and
audiobooks actually most of my friends
are dead yeah right um
the writers the definition of a reader
uh a lot of dead great dead friends so i
wanted i wanted to meet this one-way
friend i suppose didn't have a
conversation and then there's this kind
of
puzzle that i've been longing to solve
the same reason i went to ukraine
of asking this question of myself
who am i
and what was this part of the world what
is this thing that happened in the 20th
century
that i lost so much my family there
and i feel so much of my family is
defined by that place
now that place includes the soviet union
it includes
russia and ukraine it includes nazi
germany includes these
big powerful leaders
and huge
millions of people that were
lost in the beauty the power of the
dream but were also
uh the
torture
that's uh was forced onto them through
different governmental
uh
institutions
and you are somebody that seemed from
some angle
to
also be drawn to try to understand what
was that and not in some sort of
historical sense but in a deeply
psychological human sense what is that
will it repeat again in what way is it
repeating again and how can we stop it
and how can we stop it and so that's the
crucial issue i
felt i wanted to
from a very different backgrounds
uh
pull at the threat of that curiosity you
know i'm an engineer
you're
a psychologist
both lost in that curiosity and uh
both were suits
and a talk with various levels of
eloquence um
about sort of um
the shadows that these that that history
uh
cast on us
and so that was one and also the
psychology i wanted to be a psychiatrist
for a long time i was uh
i was fascinated by the human mind
and until i discovered artificial
intelligence the fact that i could
program and make a robot move and
until i discovered that magic
i thought i wanted to understand the
human mind by being psychiatrist by
talking to people by
through to talk therapy psychotherapy
now you've got the best of both worlds
because you get to talk to people and
you get build robots yeah i mean but the
dream ultimately is the robot
that i felt like by building the
thinking you start to try to understand
it yeah that's one way i mean we're all
we all have different skills and
proclivities so like my particular one
is uh has to do with
uh i learn by building yeah i i think
through a thing by building it and
programming is a wonderful thing because
it allows you to like build a little toy
example so in the same way you can do a
little thought experiment
uh programming allows you to create a
thought experiment in action it can move
it can live and can right and then you
can ask questions of it so all of those
because of my interest in freud and
young
you're also in different ways
have have
delved deeply into
um into humanity the human psyche
through the perspective of those of
those
psychologists so all for all those
reasons i thought our password across
yeah so that well so that's quite a
frame for a discussion right you had all
sorts of reasons and then you think
well are you just letting the
conversation go where it will it's like
well not exactly
you spent all this time
it's not like this came about by
accident this conversation you spent all
this time framing it and so
all of that provides the implicit
substructure for the play in the
conversation and if you have that
implicit here's another way this is very
much worth knowing is
if you get the implicit structure of
perception right everything becomes a
game
and not only that a game you want to
play and maybe in the final analysis a
game you'd want to play forever
so
you know that's obviously a distant
beckoning ideal but
we known games need rules
or there's no play
is there a device you can give
uh now that we know the frame
to give to me lex about
how to
do this podcast better how to
think
about this world how to be a good
engineer
how to uh be a good human being
from
take your preoccupation with suffering
seriously
it's a serious business
right and that's part of that to circle
back to the beginning let's say
that's that willingness to gaze into the
abyss which is obviously what you were
doing when you went to ukraine
it's like
it's gazing into the abyss that makes
you better
the thing is and this is maybe where
nietzsche's
idea is not as differentiated as it
became
sometimes your gaze can be forcefully
directed towards the abyss
and then you're traumatized
if it's involuntary and accidental it
can kill you
the more it's voluntary
the more transformative it is and that's
part of that idea about facing death and
hell
it's like can you tolerate death in hell
and the answer is
this terrible answer is
yes
to the degree that you're willing to do
it
voluntarily and then you might ask well
why should i have to subject myself to
death in hell i'm innocent
and then the answer to that is
even the innocent must be voluntarily
sacrificed to the highest good
that's such an interesting distinction
voluntary suffering voluntary yeah
yeah well that's why the central
christian doctrine is
pick up your cross and follow me
and i'm speaking
not in religious terms saying that i'm
just speaking as a psychologist it's
like one of the things we've learned in
the last hundred years is
voluntary exposure to that which
freezes and terrifies you in measured
proportions is curative
so a form of
at least in part involuntary suffering
is depression
do you have advice for people
on how to find a way out
you're a man who has suffered in this
way
perhaps continue to suffer in this way
how do you find a way out
the first thing i do as a clinician if
someone comes to me and says they're
depressed is ask myself a question
well what does this person mean by that
so i have to find out like because maybe
they're not depressed maybe they're
hyper anxious or maybe they're
obsessional like there's various forms
of
powerful negative emotion so they need
to be differentiated but then the next
question you have to ask is well
are you depressed
or do you have a terrible life
or is it some combination of the two
so if you're depressed
as far as i can tell
you don't have a terrible life
you have friends you have family you
have an intimate relationship you have a
job or a career you're about as educated
as you should be given your intelligence
use your time outside of work wisely
you're not beholden to alcohol or other
temptations
you're engaged in the community in some
fundamental sense and all that's working
now if you have all that and you're
feeling really awful
you're either ill or you're depressed
and so then
sometimes there's a biochemical route to
that treatment of that my experience as
being as a clinician is if you're
depressed but you have a life and you
take an antidepressant it will probably
help you a lot
now maybe you're not depressed
exactly you just have a terrible life
what does that look like
you have no relationship
your family is a mess
you've got no friends
you've got no plan you've got no job
you use your time outside of work not
only badly but destructively you have a
drug or alcohol habit or some other vice
pornography addiction
um you are completely unengaged in the
surrounding community you have no
scaffolding whatsoever to support you in
your current mode of being or you move
forward and then
as a therapist well
you do two things well if it's
depression
per se well like i said there's
sometimes a biochemical route a
nutritional route there's ways that can
be addressed it's probably physiological
if you're at least in part if you're
depressed but you have an okay life
sometimes it's conceptual
you can turn to dreams sometimes to help
people because dreams contain the seeds
of the potential future and if your
person is a real good dreamer and you
can analyze dreams that can be really
helpful but that seems to be only true
for more creative people
and for the people who just have a
terrible life it's like okay
you have a terrible life
well
let's pick a front
how about you need
how about you need a friend like one
sort of friend
do you know how to shake hands and
introduce yourself i'll have the person
show me
so let's do it for a sec so
it's like this hi i'm jordan
right and people don't know how to do
that and then they can't even get the
ball rolling for the listener jordan
just gave me a firm handshake yeah as
opposed to a dead fish you know and and
there's these elementary social skills
that
hypothetically if you were well cared
for you learned when you were like three
yeah and sometimes people have i had
lots of clients
to whom no one ever paid any attention
and they needed like 10 000 hours of
attention and some of that was just
listening because they had 10 000 hours
of
conversations they never had with anyone
and they were all tangled up in their
head and they had to just
one client in particular i worked with
this person for 15 years
and
what
she wanted from me was for me just to
shut the hell up for 50 minutes was very
hard for me
and
to just
tell me what had happened to her and
then what happened at the end of the
conversation then i could
discuss a bit with her
and then as we progressed through the
years the amount of time that we spent
in discussion increased in proportion in
this sessions until by the time we
stopped seeing each other when my
clinical practice collapsed
we were talking about 80 of the time but
she literally she'd never been attended
to properly ever and so she was an
uncarved block in the taoist sense right
she hadn't been subjected to those
flaming swords that
separated the wheat from the chaff
and so
you can do that in therapy
if you're listening and you're depressed
i would say if you can't
find a therapist and that's getting
harder and harder because it's actually
become illegal to be a therapist now
because you have to agree with your
clients
which is a terrible thing to do with
them
just like it's terrible just to
arbitrarily oppose them
you could do the
self-authoring program online because it
helps you write an autobiography
and so if you have memories that are
more than 18 months old that bother you
when you think them up
part of you is locked inside that
an
undeveloped part of you
is still
trapped in that that's a metaphorical
way of thinking about that's why it
still has emotional significance so you
can write about your past experiences
but i would say wait for at least 18
months if something bad has happened to
you because otherwise you just hurt
yourself again by encountering it you
can bring yourself up to date with an
autobiography there's an analysis of
faults and virtues that's the present
authoring and then there's
a
guided writing exercise that helps you
make a future plan
that's young men who do that could go to
college young men who do that 90 minutes
just the future authoring 90 minutes
they're 50 less likely to drop out
that's all it takes
so sometimes depression is this heavy
cloud
that makes it hard to even make a single
step towards it or you said isolate
make a friend oh man sometimes first
step is extremely difficult oh my god
sometimes it's it's way worse than that
like i had clients who were so depressed
they literally couldn't get out of bed
so what's their first step it's like
can you sit up
once today
no
can you prop yourself up on your elbows
once today like you just you scale back
the dragon
until you find one that's
conquerable that moves you forward
there's a there's a rubric for life
scale back the dragons till you find one
conquerable and it'll give you a little
bit of gold
commensurate with the struggle but the
plus side of that because that's you
think that god that's depressing you
mean i have to start by
sitting up
while you do if you can't sit up
but the the plus side of that is it's
the pareto distribution issue is that
aggregates
exponentially increase
and failures do too by the way but
aggregates exponentially increase so
once you start the ball rolling it can
get zipping along pretty good this
person that i talked about
was incapable of sitting with me
in a cafe when we first met just talking
even though i was
her therapist but by the end
she was doing stand-up comedy
so
you know it took years but
still most people won't do stand-up
comedy that's that's quite the bloody
achievement she
she would read her poetry on stage two
so for someone who was petrified into
paralysis by social anxiety
and who had to start very small
there's a hell of an accomplishment
yeah it all starts with one step
do you have advice for young people
in high school
you're giving a lot of people look up to
you for advice for strength
for
strength to
search for themselves to find themselves
take on some responsibility
do something for other people
you're doing something for yourself
while you're doing that even if you
don't know it
for sure because you're a community
across time
find something to serve
somebody to help someone to help
a job to find a job do your best with
the customers don't be above your job
you're going to get an entry level job
when you're a kid or what else
would you want you want to be the boss
what do you know you don't know anything
you could be the boss of your job
you know if you're working in a grocery
store or you're working in a convenience
store assuming you're not working for
terrified tyrants
you can be nice to the customers you can
develop your social skills you can learn
how to handle boss employee relationship
you can be there 15 minutes early and
leave 15 minutes late like you can learn
in an entry-level job man and i'll tell
you if you take an entry-level job and
you learn and it's a reasonably decent
place you will not be in an entry-level
job for long because everyone who's
competent is desperate for competent
people and if you go and show yourself
as competent there'll be a trial period
but if you go show yourself as competent
all sorts of doors you didn't even know
were there will start opening like mad
so you strive for competence
for craftsmanship yeah yeah yeah for
discipline
you know i mean
i i said in one of the chapters in my
books is is focused on putting your
house in order it's like well how do you
start
make your bed
you know i i it actually took me quite a
long time in my life before i made my
bed regularly in the morning most of my
life was put in pretty good order but
that was one thing i didn't have in
order
my clothes in my closet as well all
that's in order not all of it i'm
cleaning out some drawers right now but
look around and see what bugs you in
your room just look it's like okay i'm
in my room do i like this room no it
bugs me okay
why well the paint's peeling there and
it's dusty there and the carpet's dirty
and that corner is kind of ugly and the
light there isn't very good and
my clothes closet's a mess so i don't
even like to open it um okay that's a
lot of problems
that sucks that's a lot of opportunity
pick something and fix it
something that bugs you
yeah but not too much so the rule is
pick something you know would make
pick a problem
pick a solution to it that you know
would help
that you could do
that you would do
so you have to negotiate with yourself
it's like well i won't clean up this
room how do you know i've been in here
for 10 years and i've never cleaned it
up it's like well obviously that's too
big a dragon for you would you clean one
drawer
find out
and so imagine now you want to be happy
when you open that drawer and you think
well that's stupid it's like is it
maybe it's your sock drawer which i
cleaned up in my room the other day by
the way you're gonna you're gonna open
that every morning
that's like 30 seconds of your life
every day
okay so that's
three minutes a
week that's 12 minutes a
month that's two hours a year
so maybe your life is made out of you've
got 16 hours a day let's figure this out
5 12 in an hour 12 in an hour
144 in 12 hours yeah let's say 200. 205
minute chunks that's your life ladies
and gentlemen jordan peterson did just
some math how many five-minute chunks
there are in a day and i got pretty sure
that's pretty accurate it's
approximately right so
you got 200 5-minute chunks and they
repeat a lot of them repeat
so if you get every one of those right
they're trivial right who cares what my
sock drawer looks like it's like fair
enough man but that's your life the
things you repeat every day
the mundane things think i could get all
those mundane things right
that's the game rules it's like now all
the mundane is in place
now you can play because all the
mundane's in place and this is actually
true so with children
imagine you want your children to play
well play is very fragile neurologically
any competing motivation or emotion will
suppress play
so everything has to be in order
everything has to be a walled garden
before the children will play
that's a good way of thinking about it
so you put everything in order and you
think oh my god now i'm tyrannized by
this order it's like no you aren't not
if it's voluntary
and then the order is the precondition
for the freedom
and so then all of a sudden you get all
these things in order it's like oh look
at this i've i've got some room to play
here
and then
then maybe you're not depressed now it's
it's often not that simple you know it's
not that simple try putting your room in
order perfect order that's hard i mean
it's a really powerful way to think
about those five-minute chunks just get
one of them right in a day
yeah if you do that for 200 days
your life is in order yeah
you know i thought i did that with my
clients a lot so a lot of them would
come home from work the guys say and and
their wife would meet them at the door
and it'd be a fight right away
you know and it's a clash there because
he comes home and he's tired hungry he's
worked all day and he's hoping that you
know he gets welcomed when he comes back
to the home but then the wife is at home
and she's been with the kids all day and
she's tired and hungry and she's hoping
that when he comes home he'll show her
some appreciation for what's happened
today and then they clash and then they
both have problems to discuss because
they've had their troubles during the
day and so then every time they get
together
they're not like it's a bit of a fight
for 20 minutes and then the whole
evening is screwed
and so then you think okay
here's the deal
it's knock and the door will open okay
you get to pick
how what happens when you come home
but you have to figure out what it is so
now this is the deal
you treat yourself properly
you imagine coming home and it goes the
way you want and need it to go
okay
what does that look like
you get to have it but you have to know
what it is
what does it look like
and you think okay i want to come home i
want to be happy about coming home i
come home
i open the door i say hello honey i'm
home
my wife says hi it's so nice to hear
your voice she comes up she says
hi dear she gives you a hug she says how
was your day
and you say well we'll sit and talk
about that how was your day
well we'll sit and talk about that do
you need something to eat
probably
let's go sit and talk about our day it's
like that sounds pretty good okay
that sounds pretty good might not be
perfect sounds a hell of a lot better
than what we're doing now so how about
we go
talk to
we'll go talk to your wife and say okay
this is what's happening when i come
home i would like it to be better
what would you like to have happen
if you could have what you wanted and so
she sits down and she thinks okay if he
comes home what do i want to have happen
and then now you've got two visions and
you say well what would you like and
you listen and she says what would you
like can you tell her and then you think
okay now can we bring these visions
together
so not only do we both get what we want
but because we've brought them together
we even get more than we want well who
wouldn't agree to that unless they were
even down
and that's so exciting it's not a
compromise it's a union of ideals that's
even makes a better ideal and then you
get to come home and then then there's
another rule that goes along with that
which is
please dear have the grace
to allow me to do this stupidly and
badly well i learned at least 20 times
yeah
and all give you the same leeway and
then we'll practice stupidly for 20
times and we'll talk about it
and then maybe we'll get it right for
the next 10 000 times yeah right
and you can do that with your whole you
can do that with your whole life and you
can do that with your kids and you can
do that with your family like it's not
easy but you can do it's a lot easier
than the alternative
let me ask for some dating advice from
jordan peterson how do you find
on that topic the love of your life
that's a good question
i was asked that multiple times
on my tour three times in a row in fact
because we asked people to use this
slido gadget
that's a popular question two very it
always came up to the top and i got
asked that three times in a row and i
didn't have a good answer and then i
thought
why don't i have a good answer
i thought oh i know why because that's a
stupid question
so so why yeah why
because it's it's putting the cart
before the horse here's the right
question
how do i make myself into the perfect
date
you answer that question and you will
not have any problem answering the
previous question it's like
what i want in a partner
if i offered everything i could to a
partner who would i be
you work on that ask that question just
ask just ask yourself okay
i have to be the person that women
would want
okay what do they want
clean
that's not a bad start
reasonably good physical shape
so healthy
productive
generous
honest
willing to delay gratification so you
dance with a woman it's like what's she
doing what are you two doing well it's a
patterned your there's patterns
happening around you that's the music
patterns patterns of being that's the
music
now can you align yourself with the
patterns of being gracefully that's what
she's checking out
and
then can you do that with her
and then can you do that in a playful
and attentive manner
and keep your bloody hands to yourself
for at least a minute
and so
can you dance in a playful manner it's
like you can go through this in your
imagination and you know you'll know you
know and then you think well how far am
i from those things and the answer is
usually man it's pretty
horrible abyss separating you from that
ideal
but
the harder you work on
offering other people what they need and
want
the more people will line up to play
with you
so it's the wrong question it's like how
can i be the best partner possible
and then you think well if i do that
people will just take advantage of me
and that's the non-naive
objection
right because the naive person's think
well i'll be good and everyone will
treat me right it's like
the cynic says no i'll be good and
someone will
take me out
and then you think well what
do you do about that objection and the
answer is well
you factor that in
that's why you're supposed to be
what is it
as soft as a dove and as wise as a
serpent it's like i know you're full of
snakes
i know it
maybe i know it more than you do
but we'll play anyways
and that's the risk
that's right voluntarily right it's like
and that what's so cool about that is
that even though the person you're
dealing with is full of snakes
if you offer your hand in trust and it's
real you will evoke the best in them
yeah and that's true even i've dealt
with people who are
pretty damn
criminal
and pretty psychopathic
and sometimes dangerously so and you
tread very lightly when you're dealing
with someone like that especially if
they're intoxicated
and
even then
your best bet is
that
alert trust
it's the it's the only fact the only
thing i know that
if i had one client who was a paranoid
he was paranoid psychopath that's a bad
combination he was a bad guy man he had
like four restraining orders
on him and restraining orders don't work
on the sort of people that you put
restraining orders on
and he used to be harassed now and then
by you know a bureaucrat in a bank with
with delusions of power and he would say
to them he he used to kind of act this
out to me when i was talking to him he'd
say
i'm going to be your worst nightmare
and he meant it yeah and he would do it
he had this obsessional
psychopathic vengeance that was just
like right there
paranoid to the hilt and paranoid people
are hyper acute
so they're watching you for any sign
of deceit or manipulation and they're
really good at it because like they're
100 for that's what paranoia is it's 100
focus on that and
even under those circumstances if you
step carefully enough
you can
maybe
you can avoid the acts that's a good
thing to know if you ever meet someone
truly dangerous
uh absolutely i believe in that that
being fragile nevertheless
taking that leap of trust towards
another person even when they're
dangerous especially when they're
dangerous
if you care
if there's something there in those
hills you want to find
then
that's probably the only way you're
going to find it is taking that risk
i have to ask you about gulag
archipelago by soulja nitzin
that speak to this very point there's so
many layers of this book who could talk
about it forever i'm sure in many ways
we are talking about it forever
uh but there is sort of one of the
themes captured in a few ways that was
described to the book is that line
between good and evil that runs through
every
human being
as he writes
the line dividing good and evil cuts to
the heart of every human being
during the life of any heart this line
keeps changing place
sometimes it is squeezed one way to
exuberant evil and sometimes it shifts
to allow enough space for good to
flourish
one and the same human being is at
various ages under various circumstances
a totally different human being
at times he's close to being a devil
at times to sainthood
but his name doesn't change
and to that name we ascribed a whole lot
good and evil what do you think about
this line what do you think about this
thing where we talked about if you give
somebody a chance you actually bring out
the best in them what do you think about
this other aspect
that throughout time
that line shifts inside each person and
you get to define that shift what do you
think about this line
are we all capable of evil
well you know the cosmic drama that's
satan versus christ
it's like well who's that about
if it's not about you
i i'm speaking just as a psychologist or
as a literary critic those are
characters at least they're that
well are they human characters
well obviously
well are they archetypal human
characters
yes
what does that mean
cosmically and ontologically
i don't know
is the world a story
maybe but the way stories are often told
is the characters and body i know those
are those are unsufficient not great
literature though
it's very rare in great literature what
you have in great literature generally
is the internal drama right in
as the literature becomes more pop i
would say
the characters are more unitary so
there's a real bad guy and he's all bad
and there's a real good guy and he's all
good
and that's not as interesting it's not
as sophisticated
when you reach dostoevsky in heights in
in literary representation or
shakespearean heights
you can identify with the villain
and that's that's when literature really
reaches its pinnacle in some sense and
also the characters change throughout
the shift they're unpredictable
throughout uh taking the speaking of
russia more seriously recently
and i've gotten to talk to translators
of dostoevsky and tolstoy and um
czechov and those kinds of folks and you
get to
one of the mistakes that translators
made with dostoyevsky for the longest
time
is they would
quote unquote fix
the chaotic mess that is destievsky
because there was a sense like he was
too rushed in his writing it seemed like
there was tangents that had nothing to
do with anything the characters were
unpredictable not inconsistent there's
parts of phrases that seem to be
incomplete that kind of stuff and what
they realize that is that's not that's
actually crafted that way it's not it's
you know it's like editing james joyce
like finnegan's wake or something
because it doesn't make any sense they
realize that that is the magic of it
that captures the humanity of these
characters that they are unpredictable
they change their whole time there's a
bunch of contradictions
on which point i gotta ask is there a
case to be made that brothers karmazov
is the greatest book ever written yeah
there's a case to be made for that i
don't know is it better than crime and
punishment
yes yeah do you think so why do you i'm
not arguing with it why do you think
that uh well this is every every book is
a person some of my best friends are
inside that book yeah it's an amazing
book and there's no doubt about it uh i
think it's
some
books are
defined by your personal relationship
with them and that one was definitive
and i almost graduated to that one
because for the longest time
the idiot was my favorite book
uh of all
because i identified with the ideas
represented by prince michigan i also
identified oh that's interesting to
prince michigan as a as a human being
holy fool the fool because the world
kind of
my whole life
still kind of sees me saw me in my
perception my
narrow perception is kind of
the fool
and
i
different from the interpretation that a
lot of people take of this book
i see him as a kind of hero to be oh
definitely to be a naive
uh quote-unquote fool but really just a
naive optimist
and naive in the best possible way i i
do believe that
childlike yeah childlike is a butter so
naive is usually seen as that's childish
yeah but child childlike
that's why no one enters the kingdom of
heaven unless they become like a child
that's prince mishkin dostoevsky knew
that
so that's why you like the idiot that's
so interesting see i think i like crime
and punishment because while you
identified with michigan i think i
identified more with raskolnikov because
i was tempted by a luciferian intellect
you know in in in the manner that
in a manner very similar to the manner
he was tempted but i mean i think i
think you can make a case that the
brothers karamazov is
dostoevsky's crowning achievement
wow and that's something man all right
he ruined literature for me
because everything else just felt
insipid afterwards not everything not
everything
i i found some books that
in my experience
hit that pinnacle um the master in
margarita
that's a deadly book i've read that i
think four times and i still there's
still it's unbelievably deep
uh there's a nikos kazansicus a greek
writer
some of his books are
his writing is amazing as well did you
ever connect with the literary like
existentialist camus
uh or or people like carmen hesse or um
or even kafka
did you ever connect with those to the
same degree yeah to the same enough to
be an influence
you know you have to be deaf in some
fundamental sense not to encounter a
great dead friend and fail to learn
no and and i mean i tried to separate
the wheat from the chaff when i read
you know and i read all the great
clinicians all of them perhaps not
those who are foremost in the pantheon
and i tried to pull out what i could and
that was a lot i learned a lot from
freud i learned a lot from rogers and i
learned a lot from well from dostoevsky
and nietzsche i'm going to do a course
on dostoevsky and nietzsche for this
peterson academy this is coming up in
january oh that'll be
damn i'm really looking forward to it
you're weaving
i mean i hadn't thought about doing them
together oh that'd be fun that's a good
idea well that's a good idea
uh there's a feel that idea
you often weave them together really
masterfully because there is a
there is
religious
in the broad sense of that word themes
throughout the writing of both you know
there's uncanny parallelisms in their
writing in their lives
so
um
and dostoevsky's deeper than nietzsche
but that's because he was a
writer of fiction nietzsche is almost
the character in a dusty yes he is
definitely that he is definitely that
yes
and apparently nietzsche knew more about
dostoevsky than people had thought
there's been some recent scholarship on
that grounds dostoevsky didn't know
anything about nietzsche as far as i
know i could be wrong about that but
the thing that dostoevsky had over
nietzsche is nietzsche had to make
things propositional in some real sense
because he was a philosopher and
it's hard to propositionalize things
that are outside your ken but you can
characterize them and so
in the brothers karamazov ivan is a more
developed character than eliotia
in in in the explicit sense he can make
better arguments but elosha
wins like michigan because he's the
better man and dostoevsky can show that
in the actions rather
he can't render it entirely
propositional but that's probably
because what's good can't be rendered
entirely propositional
and so dostoevsky had that edge over
nietzsche said well ivan is this
brilliant rationalist atheist
materialist and puts forward an argument
on that front that's still unparalleled
as far as i'm concerned
and overwhelms eliot who cannot respond
but eliot is still the better man
so which is very interesting you know
that what
you know the funny thing about those two
characters is you jordan peterson seem
to be somebody that at least impart
embodies both
because you are one of the intellectuals
of our time
rigorous in thought
but also
are able to have that kind of
would you describe if you if you remove
the religiosity of yosha
there's a
what's a good word love towards the
world spirit of encouragement
yes
well it's it's you know one of the
things i did learn perhaps from looking
into the abyss to the degree that i have
had to
or was willing to
was that at some level you have to make
a fundamental statement of faith
when god creates the world after each
day he says
he saw that it was good
you think well is it good it's like well
there's a tough question you know do you
want to bring a child into a world such
as this which is a fundamental question
of whether or not it's good
it's an act of faith to declare that
it's good
because the evidence is ambivalent
and so then you think okay well
am i going to act as if it's good
and what would happen if i did
and maybe the answer to that is
i think this is the answer
the more you act
out the proposition that it's good
the better it gets
and so that's dostoyevsky said this is
something else
every man is not only responsible for
everything he does but for everything
everyone else does
it's like
what is that profound or are you just
insane
then you think
is what you receive back proportionate
to what you deliver
and the answer to that might be yes
that's a terrifying idea man
and it's certainly you can see that it's
true in some sense because people
certainly
respond to you
in kind with how you treat them that's
certainly the case i mean it's it's
terrifying and it's exciting yeah right
that's an adventure isn't it you uh
uh yeah
you create the world
by
the way you live it
the the world you experience is is
defined by the way you live that world
and that's really that's really
interesting and then taken as a
collective we create the world together
in that way yeah what do you what do you
think is the meaning of it all what's
the meaning of life jordan peterson
you've we've defined it many many times
throughout this conversation the
adventure along the route man
and i would say
where's that adventure to be found
in faith what's the faith
the highest value is love and truth is
it's handmade
that's a statement of faith right
because you can't tell
you have to act it out to see if it's if
it's true yeah and so you can't even
find out without and that's so peculiar
you have to make the commitment a priory
yeah it's like a marriage it's the same
thing
it's like well is this the person for me
oh that's the wrong question
how do i find out if this is the person
for me
by binding myself to them
well maybe the same thing's true of life
right you bind yourself to it
and the tighter you bind yourself to it
the more you find out what it is
and that's like a radical embrace and
it's it's a really radical embrace
that's the crucifix symbol and more than
that because like i said the the full
passion story
isn't death it isn't even unjust death
it isn't even unjust death and the
crucifixion of the innocent which is
really getting pretty bad
it's
unjust
torturous
innocent
death
attendant upon betrayal and tyranny
followed by hell
well that's a hell of a thing to
radically embrace
it's like bring it on
i think a lot of people
put truth as the highest ideal
and
um think they can get to that ideal
while living in a place of cynicism and
ultimately escape from life and hiding
from life afraid of life and it's a is
beautifully put that uh
love
is the the highest ideal to reach for
and truth is
it's handmade i thought about that for a
long time right this hierarchy of ideal
and the thing about truth that bitter
truth let's say that cynical truth is it
can
break the shackles of naivety
and actually
a burnt cynicism is a moral improvement
over
a blind naivety
even though
one is in some ways positive but only
because it's protected and the other is
bitter and dark but still better but
you're not done at that point you're
just barely started it's like you're
cynical
you're not cynical enough
it's like how cynical are you are you
i'm an auschwitz prison guard level of
cynical
because you have to be you have to go
down pretty deep into the weeds before
you find that part of you but
you can find it if you want and then you
think well i want to stop this
well that was the question you posed in
some sense you're obsessed with say what
happened on these mass scale
catastrophes
in co in the communist countries it's
like well
millions of people participated
so you could have
and maybe you would have enjoyed it so
what part of that is you
and you can find it
if you want
yeah it's it's all there the prisoner
the interrogator
the judas
pontius pilot
all of it all of it and it's all of it
is inside us yeah and you just have to
look
and once you do maybe eventually you can
find the love
jordan you're an incredible human being
i'm deeply honored you would talk to me
thank you for being a truth seeker in
this world and thank you for the love
hey
thanks for the invitation man
thanks for listening to this
conversation with jordan peterson to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description and now
let me leave you some words from
friedrich nietzsche
you must have chaos within you to give
birth to a dancing star
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time